[Music]
thank you
you
my check my check it is that time again
to return back to the realm
what's going on here
let's get some mic check see how we
doing out here
solo what's going on back for that
what's going on yeah yeah you already
know 24 hours yes we will be back doing
the light fall you know how we do yes
General Mackey OG oh hell I'll be salute
keeping respectful for sure we got to
keep it respectful Pop Lock what's going
on we're here what's up Alan Victor
what's going on live Supremacy lydian
Master he said let's get it no doubt all
right hello eventually what's going on
man Isaac Gentry what's going on what's
up Lord Mr ordinary VX no doubt yeah I'm
doing good thank you for the level check
appreciate y'all appreciate y'all black
Spartan gaming
let's go why are you scared what's going
on Deadpool Jake Paul and Tommy I don't
know I'm gonna ask King about that
because I ain't gonna lie to you like I
was into the press conference I watched
the press conference coming back off the
plane I just came in from Houston
and um
Tommy was talking that talk like that
real boxer talk so I don't know I gotta
see I don't know enough about Tommy you
know if he legit or if he's just you
know he ain't got enough experience but
yeah we'll see Robert Kelly playing my
game of the year okay okay you playing
that midnight Suns then Bill Edward
Walling what's up man good to see you
you know now dead proof you know what's
up no doubt no doubt so yeah we're gonna
get the uh Deadpool if you want Jake to
win okay Jake talking that talk we're
gonna see you know I can't wait because
if he does beat him I guess they're
gonna say yo he'll be the boxer so you
see he said Tommy my love Island boy I
can't Kevin going in
bill yeah that's the expansions needed
to get done you try to Shell it out just
cash yeah yeah it's got time life fall
is here straight the witness I'm ready
[Music]
a little late I didn't see attic yeah I
spoke to kids and I spoke to solve
she spoke the attic last night we were
up late so hopefully he gets it here the
king will be in a minute to get us a
Content strike with his theme songs and
his uncopyrighted you know his
copyrighted music so how that go anyway
good to see y'all up in here much love
in the Realms lots of fun a lot of
topics a lot of stuff to discuss but I'm
Gonna Leave y'all with these Dallas
balls and we will be bad oh hold on hold
on John again
yeah you can do that you can put a link
you can put a link down
um okay I'm sorry apologies to your
family and all that no doubt Chris of
all the stuff I see anyway we will be
back and I will get the rest of the
Lords and we're gonna try to start on
time so oh loud right back with that
last question you're getting on Destiny
today only one day left I don't know
brother like my schedule is absolutely
crazy and I got fonze show to do today
so I promise funds um we haven't looked
up in a minute
guest a lot so this is the only day that
kind of worked so I'm gonna be on games
talk live so I got a full day so we'll
see we'll see I can't promise but trust
me lightful I'm in I'll be that don't
worry about it tell it tell the clan to
hold it down
all right I gotta go I gotta go get the
rest of these loads and we will come
back
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and headers be
swearing ain't real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be using these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beat and they
want to compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all feel Dramatical I know it's random
but I'm addicted to flipping and Snapple
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's Arsen up in the apartment they call
a department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
hell look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I ain't
heard the boy and you ain't gotta say it
I'm embarrassed for you I always been a
nerd never been a loser so making
Voltron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell an Uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start it regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
[Music]
I'ma just chill and watch them and he
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they will mistake me for addict
if I can imagine it's cool to get you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't get with
that option you're gonna be single
player like sirens you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to a knee
vendor I gotta be me though I know it's
my destiny work to carnido who cares if
he flies you stealing mosquito you swear
he ain't something but really be Stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but I got bad news even if he
really was that Joe King David still be
the king of the statue sister juvenile
I've been cursed with a curse to be
Musical and if you hate
[Music]
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable because you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
LLC and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 293. this is another
Glory Sunday we're back at the round
table on the Lord's date and today got
Xbox sounding deals Nintendo and Nvidia
the bald is Gate 3 on Xbox
atomic heart Impressions excuse me
psvr2 Impressions
and McCabe leaving Tango Game Works to
discuss it so we gonna get right into it
so let's introduce you know we're
missing one right what are these guys
missing in addict send your love to
addicts
it's going through it now yeah I spoke
too he will be hopefully joining in
process so salute to him but we still
got three of them Lords of course our
most technical gaming Lord the solo game
who lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Davis the
Lord of clarity and Lord patreon of the
iron bank who I now hate because of the
lsf of it Fiasco Lord sovereign
[Laughter]
I have not seen it yet I wasn't there
live this time so I want to see are they
uploading that to patreon I gotta speak
to the coward of them I think yeah it
may be a patreon thing probably maybe
yeah okay that's what I'm assuming first
yeah I'll see it I'll see it uh at some
point during the week then yeah shout
out to you guys I know y'all did a
fantastic job well are you willing to
say what game you you are not willing to
say what game contractually I'm not
willing to say good game button okay so
check out the event man once it goes up
check it out but yeah I think I will say
this like you will appreciate it because
based on our gaming history right you're
gonna be like yeah that's right it's
gonna be one another that's definitely
it's going to be one of them when we
can't you can't we came to the crib and
he's like oh they doing that it's one of
them games
you're gonna be happy you're gonna be
because you're gonna know you were like
yeah I hate it when they do it yeah
exactly so it's good oh okay okay
so yeah it's been a pretty decent crazy
week I had a couple of days off which
wound up not being days off at all
because that's my life
um but it was a good Hardware week uh on
Monday my my baby Beast arrived um
the laptop oh that's what we doing I
knew you wasn't calling that PlayStation
VR
yo that thing is
so
um I'll talk about the psvr so okay so
remember I told you guys I was going to
get the at the Asus Rog strix whatever
so you know I did that it was yeah it
was going to come it was going to come
to like 45 like it was it was the specs
it's like the 40 90 you know whatever
and and the RAM and whatever so they
those were not coming out earliest in
the in the in the cycle they were coming
out like later in the month and I I was
impatient I was like I'm waiting I've
been excited for this um so I'm like
okay what's available now or soon and
we're like well this one's available and
it will have it like in a week so I'm
like okay let me get that it turned out
to be the most expensive laptop on the
market I went to this van get ah so I
got the MSI the MSI Titan okay
um okay okay yeah uh so it's the 40 90.
now server if you if you have 45 and you
said this one was the most expensive I
say it got to jump at least two it
jumped a thousands
and a little more than a thousand but um
I told you to jump down like I said so
yeah the 4090 uh laptop graphics card
okay 128.
I know why he's not admitting to the
price
[Laughter]
yeah so yeah so but you know I mean
again it's really it's it's nice and fun
to be like just go into a game and the
settings all just say max extreme or
whatever
oh absolutely and then and then you
couple that with like dlss3 the frame
Generation stuff like it's really kind
of Bonkers the only thing that is
stressing me out a little bit is
apparently Spider-Man remastered on the
PC has some sort of issue with like
laptop CPU specifically with multiple
cores like the new CPU
bro I throw it on right I throw it on
everything's gravy whatever I go into
the world and it's like oh no whoa and I
know how you get that disgust you when
you got like a product and it's not
Prestige you pick god of water yeah it's
game of the year right
it's good you earned it
Spiderman ran perfectly on that
Playstation four yeah but yo yeah you
know what's funny because it runs
beautifully on the steam deck yo and
it's like I'm like this 490 is not doing
it so it is it it's an issue where it
just what for whatever reason it's not
processing it correctly and it's just
Hiccup and it's nasty eyes so but
everything else runs beautifully
yeah so that and then of course we'll
talk about psvr played a little bit of
that and they it's good that's good King
it's good
save your thoughts
that's what's up yeah yeah I got mine so
yeah it was a it was a fantastic
Hardware week not so much for my pocket
but it was you know yeah you did that
you did that shout out to that 40 days
you did that oh yeah yeah yes I'm
officially again this kind of officially
takes me out of the console yeah
like is this dude without like you you
are it it's like the real master race
not like them dudes they'll be talking
masturbation they really not they
peasant rate and they run and they're
running like 10 10 70s
[Laughter]
again to anybody in the chat with no I
didn't get a desktop because for me I'm
never home so getting a desktop would
mean it would just be collecting dust
there as well with my my PlayStation my
Xbox so I needed a laptop so I figured
I'd just go for the most powerful one I
can and I mean again it's when you look
at the laptop you're like that's
portable yeah I mean portable relatively
relative yeah it's like the one that AJ
got from me that it was like a jet
engine like the bottle bro so mine
but the back part okay so the screen
doesn't flip right on the on the back
hinge right it's green flips up and you
still have more butt on the back or the
back of it yeah where the fans are you
know what the thing I hate about them
now is that like even though it's a
laptop they're so robust like you
literally cannot really utilize that
unplugged really no no no no no that was
a funny thing right because I didn't
realize I thought the Spider-Man issues
were the fact that because my the
battery I have it plugged in but once
the battery reaches 100 it'll stop
charging it'll stop charging so you stop
getting you stop getting Outlet Parts oh
I'm like oh this must have been running
on battery power that's why I wasn't
working so then I went in and I went
back in and it wasn't it wasn't the case
because everything else was running fine
but again that bad on battery life yeah
just a solo you're looking at depending
on the game you're running like if I'm
playing if I'm playing Vampire survivors
I get two hours two hours two hours if
if I'm playing a 3D intensity or
anything else yo 50 minutes yes
you better keep yeah that's the only
thing I don't like I'm like this you
really it really takes away this is
Master race
I mean you know what it is the laptops
you know that you always have to make
concessions on the laptop if you look at
how big a 40 90 is and think about what
they have to do to to to pigeonhole that
into a chassis
um so power considerations are different
obviously
um but yeah I again maybe one day I will
get the desktops set up and just put in
the living room but again I would need
to have more time
that's been it and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the access
gamer the prophet of Xbox
King of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
whoo beloved little King how are we
doing sir I'm doing fantastic for those
that don't know go see cocaine Bear
right now what
cocaine there is uh oh yeah that's right
sweep is the nation I'm telling you
right now it's a cult classic it blows
Ant-Man out the water uh attic and
myself will be talking about it on oh no
with the Lord's on at 5pm on Tuesday
it is the most hilarious movie that I've
seen in it's called cocaine cocaine beer
it's based on a true story guys
getting a hold of some kilos
it's a horror film it's a slasher film
it's a comedy is set in 1980 Something
is in the 80s I'm looking at it right
now what's going on
why you got bad powder
your girl is sensitive don't pull up
don't pull up for this one this is not
for y'all but for those dudes that will
be looking for that offensive movie to
give back to how we used to be how we
could disrespect and have fun doing it
this movie is no joke it's the best
movie I've seen so far this year
what's been going on sir
playing fortnite okay playing Fortnight
getting these chicken dinners having so
much fun because um
I got this uh this this new emote and
how many people around is how many
people can join in and link up to this
emote okay one time I almost had a whole
Lobby jumping around except for the the
fake people that are you know like the
Bots that's in there the Bots I had at
least at least 10 people in the lobby
jumping around with this uh Hallelujah
dance it's a fun thing I'm doing that uh
played atomic heart or downloaded that
you guys hear me yeah yeah you're good
um
yeah so I played atomic heart I got my
Impressions on that I downloaded my
destiny again getting ready to get
suited up and booted oh oh we get that
Jersey backwards bring the game back
together 28th we supposed to be lit we
supposed to be right back in let's be
doing it okay okay let's beg for you
you've been away not really um what
happened was um
fortnite took over
um and and Destiny got to that
repetitive you know college course thing
this week like my my season pass is
maxed out B like what why oh yo they got
new weapons in the lighthouse I'm
stacking more weapons again
for them to go to the next game and say
somebody blew up the vote
I said I'm not doing it by collecting
these weapons to make them irrelevant
because they oh this is the hottest
weapon this matter is crazy and then I
get it and then it's useless
I did all of this to get this shotgun
and nah so I was just like nope you've
already expanded [__] dude at this point
I would say yeah
so you know Halo got some stuff that's
in there yeah I heard they got a nice
little season thing going on I gotta go
check and see if they fixed up their
joint because I'm sorry to run around
looking like a Dusty spark yeah Adam
Ashley spawns just not a goal not the
way but other than that now um watch the
Cliffy beats money not to be an Ashley
Spartan yes I pay a very good mile to
look back by drip uh hello I'm here to
Echo no I don't know what I don't hear
no Echo
you still hearing it that's you I gotta
be yours anybody here you try to
actually go on that side it must be yeah
internally but anyway anything else King
no no that's about it I'm just getting
ready for uh what's about to happen soon
I was watching um can I ask you a quick
comeback to it but before our attic gets
distracted
um could uh so did I saw the press
conference with Tommy Fury and Jake Paul
yeah it was like he was talking to him
King he is like all last then they made
the bet that the persons one person get
all the purse on the winner and then the
father came up on stage and then Jake
Paul called him a fake Fury and then it
was on like I was thoroughly invested
with this place called WWE Yes Yes
um It's Entertainment this stuff is
scripted so I really don't believe
anything about it
generally uh Entertainer he scripted
this fight is scripted uh Fury is going
to go out in the eighth round okay oh
yeah bro listen if you see what happened
with Floyd was it last night like that
it was script come on he took this guy
up forget his damn name he's a MMA
fighter yeah the who from England used
to be he got he got he was on like
Geordie Shore that that version of
Jersey Shore
and then but he became an MMA fighter
and like you know you know he's he's I
think he's five and two overall
something like that um but you know
Floyd I'll clustered the whole time and
then they get you know they don't
there's no decision at the end no what
oh no but that was that's some
exhibition exhibition yeah yeah but they
said all right
they saying that Jake Paul when he gonna
get a ranking from the WB yeah they
trying to okay so you know how when they
trying to f up your sport
like like you you know well like okay so
remember when Tim Tebow wasn't supposed
to get the shot at baseball
[Laughter]
in there because he bringing ratings
can't really give him a shot because
when we really put him out there with
the real people he gonna look like oh
okay so I see what you said so basically
your check boxing is taking advantage of
Jake Paul's it makes popularity so okay
I see where you go so when he get in
there with somebody real so do they real
cause he sound like he a fury he boxy
okay so let me ask you a question this
can answer it all okay have you heard of
him died
I thought he was an up-and-coming dude
okay
the difficult game conqueror Lord of his
old world and the how of the young wolf
my man Lord addict that we don't hear no
attic Echo with so how we doing I I hear
an echo everything I say
but let me leave and come back all right
so he gonna leave and come back by and
do this intro awesome so um
you hear me hear me hear me hear me hear
me hear me
a little addicts start popping off yo
Senpai said yo what's up Louis why kick
out here looking like the white wolf
okay okay that's right listen man I
stopped on the master Mark some record
right there yeah yeah yeah
exactly remember the seafood when you
get the area yeah yeah
see if we're coming soon
because it's not in PlayStation I went
over there I was like yo let me get a
hold of that C4 he said nah you see fool
over there when he get it to you
yo shout out to Paris he said brother
Fury is the GoBots to the
transit
he's the lexicons
[Laughter]
but I just got so busy so apologies to
all my Houston family everybody that
pulled up man so much love the event was
phenomenal the the the like everything
about it not only the community elephant
Community is one of the best there's no
doubt like the amount of Love they
showed the kid it was it was humbling
man we came out there we did that shout
out to all of y'all for y'all frauds
I know what y'all did y'all was
selective to slander me and do y'all
little video stuff or or Trio
listen wait wait till you see the
unedited
then you didn't hear it because it's
it's it's at the end of it because if
you still sort of edited joint oh yeah
oh no I didn't see that I pretty much
took like all of our responses and made
funny
if you like soft sent me his original
it's like eight minutes long oh wow you
were hilarious at the end I finally
caught that Joy saw which is straight
just I was like yo it was so just it was
funny it was like yo you need his bag it
was so disrespectful I was I was
concerned yeah
he's like the hentai stuff yeah
like
um I I think Locke knows that I'm really
the only one that's kind of in LSM
besides you know I'm down with the
patreon so he he he listen you know what
happened during the first show yes and
he was like this is we're going to be
talking about the most overrated game
she's like stop you know the assignment
right I was like yes I do sir yes I do I
didn't know the assignment yeah I had no
idea he was lost everybody worked out
great I love the fact that you use
addict right at the end of it it was
good
shout out you know what it was is I came
back in the frame yeah you came back you
got your Facebook and doing that foolish
I was like all right you're gonna you're
gonna hate my guts after you see them
crazy it's crazy so shout out to y'all
it did uh of jaffeine and Gene Park I
see it up in there Jimmy Jimmy champagne
was up in there you know I'm saying I
want to give us a couple shout outs um
shout out to the homie Sean Mason he's
in our Discord he's all he always comes
to all the events um yo it was so cool
to see him that brother has been through
a lot on this video he has today y'all
was dope um a lot of people shot my man
Hodge he was up in there show Wild Love
um shout out to my man Astro pan I met
actually that's the dude who every show
he'll he'll text out IOP without context
yeah he's I bet they do yeah crazy
though did you eat donuts
Don was in there in the back when he was
doing questions and they asked him and
he there was a segment of the show where
there was a straight Sega slander and I
had to come for Kyle I was like you out
of pocket you're out of pocket right now
you do way too much because his game was
wild slandered but in a way he wasn't
really wrong with his choice but we'll
get to we all got to watch the show but
not during that segment Don lutaku was
in the back and he grabbed a bike and he
was like yo this daughter did he
consider this land of Genesis and I was
like bro what are we doing what are we
doing
it's in the super chat but he said that
he said the digging was wild
go up
people I just spoke to Chris I said
Chris Frank I just hope he's safe
brother I just hope he's safe I hope you
got every because you're a full-time
boxer now you might get kicked off
yo why I'm telling you all right it is
an amazing event Houston was love shout
out to Houston barbecue we went to a
spot literally called the truth you know
what I'm saying amazing mac and cheese
like the whole vibe you know what I'm
saying but I have to check in with Jay
Prince this time kick I was okay okay
because I didn't want you to go around
no I was right next to the police
station so just in case
yeah you got yeah yeah you gotta be
careful you know say the prince family
is awesome
what's up what's up
I'll I'll give you guys this uh you know
what Chris Ray got done I think a lot of
you guys will enjoy yeah it's a lot to
tell you you already know wow and of
course uh gaming Lord who missed his
intro right after but how are you doing
sir
doing pretty good uh uh I have my uh my
girlfriend's daughter today while she
was working so normally my mom gets here
to walk to take her or watch her during
the podcast but past couple weeks it's
been like hit and miss they get here on
time but uh yeah I'm here and then I get
on in here myself echo and I got off the
uh the headset and I was hearing myself
echo there too and I was like what is
going on I think it was that program I
think that's what oh okay I thought you
was saying it was in your ears
what you've been playing for years
uh the only I'm not allowed to talk
about it yeah I'll just see if you're
gonna break into your now let's go I'm
not allowed to talk okay you you guys
will see here soon
is next week sometime yeah but uh you
guys will see here soon no doubt no
doubt and uh yeah for me it's been like
I said I just brought to Steve deck on
the play Marvel I mean that sounds one
runs very good
I'll tell you yeah got that little demu
um unfortunately my P my V psvr2 came
literally the day before about to fly
out so it's literally in the Box I'm
like oh man should I get a chance but I
did test dbo console version or PS5 oh
crap fantastic job chance fantastic they
look so good I go for like you know what
it is I I this is my first time playing
demio on an OLED
because technically prior to that I did
play the PC version but I don't have no
the OLED screen or anything like that yo
team yo getting kind of different or
that old actually I was like ah
it's actually to get on this you know
what I'm saying resolution take all the
bags you need right you know what I'm
saying so um and they don't seem like
it's a marketing deal so Xbox people bro
I'm telling you man that that's going to
be one and they got full cross play so
I've been rocking that and then um all
the steam Jack I had I bust out the tech
at seven bro I was oh yeah that was nice
beautiful did you see it because
a trailer where they fighting in Times
Square
and a drink it looked nice too
Causey you're looking crazy that game
looks how harada shot I need a date we
getting it this year where we getting it
bro you know fighting games this year we
got the confirmation that we got you
know from an earnings call that we're
gonna get okay we're gonna Mortal Kombat
you know what I'm saying No Doubt no
doubt but I spent it for me you want to
do the uh super Chester do you want me
to describe now ah let me do the super
chats
we got Nintendo on the otaku remember
for one year five dollar Super Chat I
just want wanted to shout out Cog and
Ellis M the event in Houston was fire
and the Highlight was me slander and
Sega in front of a live crowd with [__]
press he was wild disrespectful he was
wild disrespected but you know what
Eddie respectful kid you know he did
that was fun he had one of the moments
he broke the rule that you're not
supposed to do which is you know when
your man get a new system invite you
over oh man he slanted his bad system
with his man showed up the Genesis
you know how the Super Nintendo had to
do
genesis was all befolding it too before
I guess he just didn't have it he
doesn't have it oh man oh oh okay that
dude kind of makes sense you wouldn't
wrote a Genesis after you saw the Super
Nintendo
absolutely yeah
Taco again remember before we did five
dollar Super Chat also as a moderator
with point one percent stake in IOP I
use my power to ban digging Moriarty
never showing his face mad
disrespectful they get winning or
something Endo slander did he drop we
can't like I said you gotta watch the
show but digging came for a lot of
people hard I was like wow he did that
okay then we have Robert Kelly Two
Dollars to protect did the joysticks
scare off addict no addict is here no
the joysticks did not scare off Abby
he's afraid he was gonna get a joystick
of his own today
somebody could change their name
entertained exactly hilarious then we
got free on Kelly five dollar Super Chat
not a lot of news this Sunday hopefully
the next day to play brings Sony back to
stand it ain't nobody care with Xbox and
Nintendo got going on right now
Kelly Kelly if you can can you change
the profile picture you know what video
I just came across that I had I forgot
about it which one it was it was R Kelly
with Cassidy the hotel but he starts out
with the pink Zorro
[Laughter]
this gentleman is already a super
chatter before so he's not he's not
distant King this is his own name yes
King is overrated
he's trying to come off the whiskey from
last night and the round table is gonna
help with waking me up thank you brother
you can get that Focus happy to help me
see you see what it is
yeah and I got it in Lord's cup yeah
put that weapon down
oh well for sure I got I got two scoops
today
shout out to East Texas Alex put the
crest in the chat for East Texas Alice
for gifting five IOP memberships shout
out to you absolutely
then we have Nintendo Taco once again
two dollar Super Chat hearing solve was
wild and out of character for me yes yes
that was definitely solved after dark
yes like I said like I said LACMA was
like Saab you know the assignment I was
like yes yes I do
Xbox Shadow drop Game of the Year
Contender Nintendo Shadow dropped remake
of a game of all time their greatest of
all time Contender then we have
PlayStation Shadow dropped Mass
emotional damage too wow messy messy let
me see what else then we have Robert
kellett once again two dollar Super Chat
so Suicide Squad sounds more like DOA
fam I I liked what I saw but it is very
polarizing it seems it is polarizing
people I just to me if the story stuff
is good that the craziness of the open
world if it plays out that way because
again I don't know if that was straight
up gameplay that was a vertical slice we
will see how it plays we'll see no doubt
you're saying that it was gameplay real
quick we got the legendary Lord from it
from Lords gaming.net just want to make
his bike make sure his bike is okay give
us a little mic check sir yeah you tell
me Oh no you're good yeah you sounded
good you sounded good no doubt so we all
sat with the uh we have two more
second let's get Nintendo on the otaku
once again two dollars will be Chad
Street Fighter 6 clears Tekken eight
easily sadly whoa whoa watch your mouth
we not good enough we're not doing that
sir but respectfully that's your choice
are you crazy that's what I said that's
why we had to leave the room and we had
to leave Rockstar there because
we're all dying all of us are dying I'm
just saying Rockstar gotta go yeah we
got drunken ninja better for 30. what's
Lord bronze good morning ILP Robin
Williams boy good morning
you like that I like that happy Sunday
to the realm let's get this bread yes
yes let's get that get it yes oh no
we're not good we got one more we got
okay you miss
oh we got face 23 beat can why 20 Super
Chat I see no topic on the world's
powerful console getting curb stopped
consistently in performance by the PS5
okay what did you guys say for this
kick it solid
King is beauty not not me me me
basically I'm just staring at him
you gotta gotta pull the glasses down no
no he don't get that
you don't get that sir you just get to
me to just look at you you wanted a
reaction
you don't get nothing thank you twenty
dollars
right
if that's true and you repping this rat
right because you're a rap rap rapper
you rap from this rap we don't do this
in the street so I can't I can't really
identify with him that's why I just
heard them all the most powerful console
if you're the most powerful console
y'all the market leader why y'all
snitching
[Laughter]
you do all the illegal tactics yeah you
never seen Goldberg mess with nobody
turnbuckle
yo
anyway are we building voices no we got
a couple that came in we got Robert
Kelly once again two dollars to the chat
why are people saying Mid State should
be stronger
there we go black boxing Kings two
dollars Super Chat are you guys playing
in tournaments not anymore skills ain't
there I don't maybe Chicago could jump
back in I don't know about me I mean
technically depends it depends I might
depends on what I got smoke by hip hop I
thought I went in there with that old 90
yeah oh that you came in with the 95
combo PlayStation one combos I thought I
could just get in there
guys young boys to tell you up
what else we gotta say we're caught up
with all right we are finally caught up
we have some very patient guests in the
round but yeah it is that time that time
of the month where we celebrate Lords of
gaming.net shout out to the amazing team
amazing scribe look man we just hit
arguably one of our highest traffic
Buffs ever since the sites existed put
your hands together for Lords game
without that first of all keep killing
it absolutely killing it you know I mean
we finding our Niche we doing the
opinion pieces we're doing the
editorials we're doing the reviews we're
getting them notoriety the sourcing has
been fantastic everywhere I go people
have been really positive about it for
people I respect and then also people
really want to get down with the team
and it just really gonna show the hard
work so shout out to everybody on the
squad but uh of course now it's time to
celebrate you know one particular scribe
went Above and Beyond in the month of
February you want me to read this in my
French accent okay
you can do that
you wanna wait till I'm finished
disappearing yeah no no yeah exactly
okay cool no no social look man this
this guy has been this Lord this scribe
has been excellent absolutely hilarious
with the comics the board games you know
what I'm saying and he has a really cool
um it's kind of like PC or the next Fest
like all the upcoming demos all the
stuff that's covered articles have been
the last for me personally he's got this
comic Wiki series he picks like some
random Comic character reads the wiki
King he got Plastic Man on blast son I
forgot about Patrick remember terrible
Plastic Man the most horrible uh
with that deck go to Comic Wiki's my man
you know what I'm saying he's got one of
the funniest articles and he brings
Huber to the site in a very unique field
so we proudly present the latest winner
of the Lord dizzy long neck scribe of
the month to Lord song
AKA love cheese
AKA David challenge
so yeah thanks so much well uh you know
I didn't really prepare much of anything
mostly I just want to say you know I
really appreciate you guys uh taking me
on and uh obviously I really appreciate
that you apparently enjoy what I'm doing
so I plan to just keep it up and uh you
know I'm getting close to where I can
start uh put reviews out so I'm very
excited about that so yeah um I'm gonna
just keep uh working on the wiki stuff
trying to do that once a week so see
where that goes love it man I love again
love what you bring and and the humor
you're bringing the fun back to the ride
again that's what it's all about man and
again I love the the board game stuff is
pretty interesting too I haven't done
that in a while and um it's cool to have
that take as well so you got the ball
game the comics all that good stuff so
keep up the good work and of course hit
launch solve so you get your reward and
hopefully it doesn't take two months
yeah we need to baptize you we got it
apparently how many lashes how many
lashes oh I don't know man it's one of
those you're gonna be walking through
the streets getting stuff slime yeah
Game of Thrones shame Teespring you
making us look bad out here baby's
terrible yeah so get it together you'll
get it by Christmas we will take care of
you we would not you would not be lost
probably apparently my address has to be
like a drop service and I have to
forward everything but brother thank you
again for taking the time today the
Scribe of the butt the problem is thank
you so much brother no doubt and of
course we got another award that we want
to give Lords gaming.net again this is
more in my honor of my brother dizzy you
know what I'm saying like again he was a
nurturer of talent you know he was an
editor he was a person who you know
gives you don't get the well you're an
editorial when you're in the auditorial
y'all feel you get the proper credit you
get because you're so much behind the
scenes stuff you do you're looking at
other people's world you're making sure
your team should give the lifeblood of
the site this editor he's a prime
example of consistency you know what I'm
saying he's accountable and uh he's a
good communicator he's a good kid
despite his ridiculous passion for
Warframe you know I don't know but
um no look he he loves his jrpgs and uh
of course his octopaths his childhood
strategies and all that and he will
definitely put that Warframe information
he even got recognized by the company
based on um you know how how passionate
how informed the articles are so salute
to my man proudly present Lord dizzy
logged that editor of the month of
February to my man Lord flame AKA Joseph
Repco put your damn hands together
anyways yeah so everything's right oh
your bike's working yes yes okay part of
you wanted to just put Destiny words
let's talk Destiny talk that he loves
Destiny again
I'm not gonna let you guys take
advantage
what's up brother congratulations
fantastic Buck fantastic [__] it
was and I just gotta say right now like
this month was really great I've got
Chris killing it with his VR and Views
uh of course I even Chronicles stuff uh
foreign
[Music]
and Jean and his wall like
like he is already killing it with PS4
too articles and yeah both objectives
there's no joke yeah the article too
about the Kings King happy about
Kingston he'll talk about later yes
certain issues you know what it feels
real good when I can take uh my topic
from our site and I could just be real
proud of the work you know while we
mentioned that while we mentioned that
shout out to everybody that uh that
cited other websites as being the first
ones
no no no no no because I if I recall
correctly
I saw that go up at one in the morning
two in the morning and then everybody
else followed suit and all of a sudden
but when people reference it it's on
this site this site that site yeah
once I say my goals everyone had to fix
that yeah so that shoes and Philly clubs
something like that we're gonna tie
PlayStation 5S around the ankles oh yo
we got 612 in here only 173 likes I
don't know what the hell is going on but
wipe your feet and ring the bell when
you walk in my house please please
anyways
um what I was gonna say was that I just
feel very honored to be honest with so
many amazing writers and just be honest
whenever I joined in 2021 in June I
didn't think I was gonna last this long
so thank you for having me on putting up
with me and
it's been a great time thank you you're
essential to the site in a short time
you've been absolutely killing it you
bring to him where you bring the fun and
he's funny as hell yeah the article
quality is is tremendous so keep up the
Fantastic work proud to work with you
and uh looking for what's going on uh
with Warframe next month and it's late
for comes out
all right that's next week for you guys
yeah but
um on Friday they actually have a uh
showcase for their next expansion so if
anybody wants to keep up with that
security Paradox if you all heard about
that since 2018 in Warframe because they
showed it off it was pretty major
definitely go ahead and just keep an eye
on it and if you can't watch the stream
I will definitely have a thorough
breakdown on Friday well this upcoming
Friday and we hope to see you there and
a little doubt thank you very much it's
been an honor been an honor by the
salute speak this off hopefully we get
your thing
lasting four months this time
[Laughter]
Alvin five dollar Super Chat in case
folks forgot John Lindeman still says
Xbox has more wins this gen that's why
it's a story when PlayStation gets one
oh that was the face uh 23 clap back
yeah yeah
you already know the route was ready
they ain't trying to hear it okay okay
then we got robbed the Don 202 two
dollar Super Chat get the likes up
people let's get them likes get the
likes up y'all let's get the likes
that we got Astro parrot King five
dollars
shout out to astral parrot King five
dollar Super Chat hello beautiful Lords
thank you Cog for making Houston
fantastic shout out to IOP have a cog
match my hype energy and made it my
years
he pulled up he's on the line he's doing
the signings and I was like I already
know he had the Hat I was like oh that's
him yeah
salute to him the energy was positive
brother and I saw y'all went to there
they had a spot they got a spot like you
know how we got Barcade they got a spot
why are you laughing
um
they got a spot called Cider arcade
and stuff with bro all the classic
arcade stuff they had the Shinobi they
had only every arcade oh yeah I had to
show up I had to show them so it was
funny that he was playing until he
showed me a picture of it so salute to
actual power kick absolute pressure
brother he's he's the Dual kid that an
attic he's the one that does the um
IOP spoilers with no context oh that's
what's up yeah that's that's my Miss
absolutely you know that let's get these
super chats they funny
we got a little more back slap remember
for 32 months Lord bronze you know what
it is Warframe is greater than Destiny 2
trailer which is greater than actual
Destiny 2 content
you know what I like about about slovo
he don't talk about division though
yeah you know what I like I like now
that he got to get a new chip I like
like Destiny kills all their Champions
and then like now they die they get
behind the new Champion
they turn them into amp yeah yeah yeah
did you see that you're right slow mo I
I saw the video I saw the trailer and I
was like it's like our end begins I was
like thank God did you see that uh they
had a astrocross had a
a video where he was ranking all the
destiny Killers yeah all he had to where
was where was dog division yeah he uh I
don't know I didn't watch it it was like
it was like 40 minutes long or something
like I'm gonna go see the ranking from
my man he was he was ranking the destiny
Killers yo it's beef in the chat
yes though first let's start off with
the the initiator
homie yes you know minutes
The Horizon forbidden West came out he
was forbidden to talk you ridiculous
ten dollar Super Chat what up Lords
don't it feel good to be a PlayStation
gamer put your nose up high and smell
the PlayStation fragrance
it smelled like rat oh
it smelled like snitching
don't do that don't do that yeah
ain't nobody trying to smell that nasty
stuff Barry oh
we could have read it
it's uh the PlayStation Nation they
feeling good this week a lot of good
stuff with the 50 dollar clap back thank
you Barry appreciate it
Nintendo step it up bro you saving a lot
of money with Game Pass bless my guys up
pocket watching by me
don't do them like that damn
because the PlayStation video ain't had
no games
we got he got oh Horizon Dawn call of
the West Coast
you stupid you're stupid yeah smelly
wrestling geek
after that state of play Playstation
smelling how to foul right now
I gotta pay seventy dollars for Zelda um
I feel that you budgeting brother
exactly it's a rough month coming up
March is going to be crazy then we got
Hollywood rules remember for 13. what's
Louis Silva thank you sir happy Sunday
IOP my favorite podcast Lulu making like
King out there collecting these on
Twitter
I just know she outside with these
babies
you start snitching real one starts
showing up then we have that there's a
PlayStation fragrance all right
[Laughter]
y'all disrespectful Ratatouille
continue yeah we have Joseph rapco AKA
flame member for 28 months what bronze
all of this Warframe love in the chat oh
my [__] I guess number one on the site
isn't just a flu game love you guys have
a great song
you know what I love about them they
over they over exaggerate everything
yeah
look I have y'all booming brother y'all
doing that thing I'm allowing y'all to
rock out cause y'all need that y'all
need to feel good after Destiny killed
all your games but I respect y'all live
service dudes
Robert Kelly stupid chat Calvin called
The Wild looking mighty mid wow
we will discuss let's show Jay Murray
play hashtag stop the deal
yo
are we caught up yes sir we're all
caught up shout out today so we got the
poll and if we're gonna get into these
towers is absolutely hilarious uh live
streams are people are in the people
have spoken to the question
um which third party game pass game do
you think will cannibalize sales yet
generate the most increase of
subscribers once it hits the service the
winner of the four-way ILP poll 28 of
vote this was a dead Lock between three
years
whoa long fallid Dynasty so they fell
along it's gonna be the one but this is
very close coming in second place raise
it close 25 percent of the vote was lies
of P lies of p a lot of lives of P fans
that replace 24 of the vote was atomic
heart which we will discuss so we'll
discuss later and in last place with 21
of the vote was MLB the Show so really
close all along I want to give this to
attic man you know what I'm saying where
you at whoa long they should feel that's
gonna be the one
[Laughter]
[Music]
there are other YouTube Outlets agreeing
with King that Sony might become a third
party developer if they don't sign that
deal really yeah I didn't see that
interesting got to get you gotta swallow
that poison pillar
drink up
yes sir let me see if anything Kyle's
jumped in no we're good all right so
this is big y'all know I'm kind of done
with this activation blizzard stuff yeah
you got to talk about it we have to talk
this was a big week for certain things
so um salute to Xbox salute to uh
Microsoft and uh looks like Microsoft
Nintendo have officially negotiated a
10-year deal to bring Xbox games to
Nintendo Gamers according to Brad Smith
Vice chair president of Microsoft and um
he states that this Nintendo agreement
currently right now is just for the Call
of Duty uh specifically that game and
then Xbox has also signed a 10-year deal
with Nvidia to bring all Xbox games that
are on PC to nvidia's cloud gaming
service GeForce now eliminating previous
competition concerns in the cloud gaming
area when this concern is addressed the
video states that they are now in
support of Xbox's acquisition of
Activision Blizzard and then the other
third part which I thought was kind of
big was um there's a lot of talk before
like um you know what are the
concessions be to kind of divest Call of
Duty right to cap Call of Duty out of
the equation so not according to uh Brad
Smith he said dropping Call of Duty was
proposed by UK's regulatory body as a
possible way for the acquisition to go
through but it looks like Microsoft is
not interested in the option when asked
about the possibility of divesting from
Call of Duty Smith commented we don't
think it's feasible or realistic to take
one game or one slice can be carved out
from the rest so Microsoft has made it
clear that they are interested in Call
of the duty being part of this deal
including King all of the duty yeah call
of the duty I guess it's it's more than
movable there so they made it very clear
they look like they will walk away from
that so yeah this is the hot one so
let's bring it across the board Lord man
how did you feel now that you um heard
this news you know what do you feel
about them partner attending signing a
10-year deal with Nintendo starting to
deal with Nvidia you know Call of Duty's
part of it what do you feel about all
this
what's that um the dude that's on uh
ESPN or something he's like okay I'm
gonna be real we don't care Oh Steven
Smith
yeah because they're like oh we're gonna
bring Call of Duty I don't play Call of
Duty I don't care we're gonna Recology
in that video okay I don't care I don't
play Call of Duty like I
I I use I've never really been a big
Call of Duty that was the top of my life
where I played a good amount of
um I think it was Black Ops 2
um but that's it that that's that's the
extent of my Call of Duty life I might
play some zombies here and there but
that's all and let me ask you this you
you can bring that to so you can bring
that to Windows phones and it wouldn't
bother to me you know you could bring
that on the on the
on the refrigerators where's touch play
stuff just doesn't matter to me let me
ask you this I totally get you all Call
of Duty I think me and you agree that
I've kind of like as big as Call of Duty
I've kind of fallen out of it but I
guess my question is you know you like a
lot of Blizzard titles you know you got
Diablo in there and stuff like that but
you play Blizzard game so what about
that aspect in terms of the deal going
through and then just like for example I
mean Nintendo's not getting blizzard
games it seems you know saying but um
just like it going to other platforms
like how you feel about that
it already is on multiple platforms so
like to me it would be relevant if it
like benefited me and but it is
because it go it goes to Nvidia okay
like to me what what like in this the
grand scheme of things like what does
that offer me as an Xbox game or nothing
okay so you're just not interested in
any of these games
I I mean I've been very vocal since day
one that I wish it was Sega so like
because I I don't I don't mess with
Activision games like almost at all like
I'll I'll play some blizzard games like
I I like OverWatch OverWatch that's all
Diablo I don't touch the elbow okay I
think I played the third one once I
actually have a couple videos they got
some viewership from the third one but
like that's all like like that that's
why I've always said like
this this deal is mainly for
like a casual audience to get the masses
in the game pass and that's cool but
like they they ain't me so I got you
know I respect that I respect you
basically say like regardless of this
deal get blocked and uh you good
regardless and last question before I do
I got a funny one um so let's just say
get blocked
what are you what do you want Xbox to do
I want to buy Sega
okay it's interesting but you with the
sake of love it's okay okay because Sega
actually got games I like like okay
okay at least they have the the Yakuza
people that made the white dragon you
know I I do enjoy Sonic to a degree it's
like they got stuff that I actually want
likes look there's a lot of people out
there that like Call of Duty there's a
lot of people out there that like a lot
of this stuff blizzard makes I'm just
not one of them so respectful it gets
blocked it doesn't get blocked like I've
been ready for this thing to end the
moment it got announced the moment
they're like okay you know it's gonna be
a little bit I'm like oh my God you're
like oh damn you got more topics every
year yeah it's literally like I told
colg after one one IOP I was like man we
can't talk about that unless it's like
huge girls absolutely uh Nintendo and
then obviously they they said they've
they pretty much vocalize that they were
gonna make an agreement but this is them
actually making the game but it was
worthy of talking about but it's just
like as far as like the overall
perspective of them buying it I
understand why they're doing it I just
don't care they're doing I respect that
no doubt Lord solve Nintendo 10-year
deal Nvidia 10-year deal you're now
Master race now you know and then
obviously the the divesting aspect the
deal must have Call of Duty for xBox to
continue otherwise they ain't feeling it
so where you at
there you go
the divesting part let's get it let's
get it come come on like that was never
going to happen like yeah listen I as as
much as
the acquisition of King is huge just
because of the underlying current of
just free money coming in all the time
without with minimal work being put in
right compared to a big AAA game
um
the star of the show is Call of Duty
right the reach Call of Duty even kind
of more than mobile games another way
has shown that it has this ability to
thrive year in and year out with a new
product even when products are kind of
mid right and not up to the level of
what people expect from Call of Duty
every single year uh I kind of don't
understand it but I see it and I can't
deny that it exists so this is the star
of this show regardless of all the
underlying things that make it make it
viable and make it worthy of doing um
that are just smaller in scale nah you
can't do it without Cod I'd walk away
without Cod yeah pay that three billion
hey it's not gonna work I'm sorry but
I'm not doing it without Devil's
Advocate real quick interrupt what about
prior statements that right the deal was
solely about mobile we can't exist
without the mobile market in our foot so
that's the real thing I think what we've
all seen and this this is going to my
next point is the fact fact is
because of the pushback on this deal
Microsoft has been forced to show their
true hand which is up front
earlier than they would have liked to
right the fact of the matter is and and
not to say that they've been hiding this
but when you look at Game Pass and what
game pass is they've always touted game
pass to be it is about getting the Xbox
ecosystem onto as many platforms as
possible correct right
even the resistant ones right would they
love to have it on place and yes they
would love to have it on places Jim Ryan
says hey put it on Playstation Bill
Spencer will put it on Playstation so
the Xbox the thinking of Xbox and what
they want with Game Pass is
the truth of it is that you know Xbox
Xbox really really been for the streets
this is Day Day all of this yes they're
gonna continue to make a console and if
you love Xbox they they you know hey be
there be there fantastic but they've
made it known we are for the streets we
want to be for the streets anybody who
wants some of this you can guess some of
this we have no issue and statements
it's just the truth I mean if you think
about what game pass is and what they
want it to be and where they wanted to
be that's just the truth now the the the
out and out truth like the hardcore Xbox
console guys yes yes man I'll be happy
with that right but in the long term
what's good for the goose was good for
the game if we're telling PlayStation
hey you got to do this because you gotta
you gotta spread the wealth this crazy
ecosystem is is not gonna help you in
the long term right you need to be on PC
you need to be on these other platforms
Xbox is shown from the beginning with
game pass this is what they want to be
has it been and this is another step
towards that right and to me it just is
absolutely them having to show kind of
their full cards on the table before
they really wanted to and that's fine
but these deals in my mind were gonna
happen anyway this idea of using and you
know and GeForce now it's crazy
like xcloud is right below it but it
does yeah like GeForce now is is bro
they're using 40 90s in that Journey
yeah yeah they're using 490s now so you
you're getting RTX and stuff like that
forever
they're all in the server blades yeah
yeah the inverted blades and they're
charging you for them putting it up
that's why them 49ers these guys are
crooked and this and it's 20 what 25 a
month or something yeah Master race baby
but um and then on the Nintendo side
except for Spider-Man well you know
again this is the Sony resistance
but but and then the Nintendo the
Nintendo thing is interesting too right
because when you see the stuff that
they've done so far Cloud wise on
Nintendo none of it works very well at
all like so the The Hope and the
expectation there is that in addition to
the games coming to it and whatever that
the the underlying guts of how that
works is all also going to be side of
you know Microsoft working on that right
because otherwise if we're thinking of
of a solution that's beyond just Cloud
that means that Nintendo's next machine
oh Hardware wise is at least somewhat
capable of running modern games right
right so that that's interesting and
made I I won't say excited yet because I
gotta wait because it's Nintendo we
gotta relax but all of it is showing
that
like I said that's Microsoft's true hand
they want to be everywhere and they're
willing to do whatever it takes to be
everywhere did they necessarily want to
say that just yet not really I don't
think so but it is what it is you got to
get this deal done which is why you see
them in you know documents that we
aren't supposed to be seeing saying like
hey
PlayStation's whipping our butt up up
and down like you know they're all this
how can we how can this purchase affect
the industry so much that all of a
sudden we're going to dominate that
doesn't make any sense and you have to
again you have to come out and say that
and you have to put yourself in a weak
position the same way that Jim has been
doing from the beginning we can't we
can't coexist exactly so the little
Little Theater both of them yeah both a
little theater so um I just find it
interesting that again the cards are on
the table now it's as clear as day what
they want to do it's as clear as they're
what they're willing to do
um I don't think we would have seen
these deals just yet right if it had it
not been for the urgency of it happening
uh especially on the day where they're
they you know the the FC the FTC and the
and the European commission is like okay
this is what we feel counter it right
and they countered it with you know
addressing the specific things they were
addressed in in in in these documents
indicating why the deal shouldn't go
right the whole competition exactly so
they addressed it in the most direct way
possible yes
um so it's it's very interesting to see
because these are inner one kings that
we're not supposed to be seeing and we
have to see it because this has to play
out in a public forum now
um but again for those of you who
thought that Xbox hell everything is
just for Game Pass and console and all
that other stuff is nice but it doesn't
matter no this is where they want to be
and if you think about what Xbox has
always been from the beginning
what Bill Gates wanted the Xbox to be
the DirectX box he wanted to control
your living room he wanted to control
everything from that Hub and it it's all
of that coming to fruition
bill
I don't know
do you know the muffin man you know the
muffin man so again I just think it's
funny that all this stuff has to come
out now in the way that it's coming out
but it it just is what it is so it's
exciting to really how did all that
stuff come out
because of snitching
snitching and these dudes still roughing
these guys I can't see it
it's like cake is is ready King is
primed I I passed the ball off dude
a 10-year deal with the Xbox and
Nintendo and then uh another 10-year
deal signing with Nvidia Microsoft
outside saying we will not die fast
let's play a game take a shot every time
King says snitching in the side
Take a Shot beside these shorty dudes so
those are the two of them so what are
you doing oh the cash is
he said how how can I get you on my side
of the fence Nvidia
oh they had their version of buck yes
how can I get you on my side of the
fence man
Nvidia easy
Phil told you long time ago Nintendo was
in Pocket y'all just wasn't looking at
facts the Shelf did say that Chef told
you preach the person that wasn't in
Pocket was Nvidia
so that deal already been signed by
Nintendo
but they remember what tech is inside
the Nintendo
and video talking talking
all right so that Tech is inside the old
techmanship so hopefully we get new
Tegra chips that's able to uh to do some
Nvidia Gold Game Pass Inside the Box
okay so we're waiting Nintendo was like
the Inside Man for Mexico whoa they had
to connect the broker analyzing this
Nintendo's the only one that's giving
these dudes money
[Music]
remember uh AMD got Sony and Microsoft
to freeze Nvidia out
so they're the only link into this so
and Nintendo went over to Nvidia and
told them Yo Don't You Buck up on me
don't mess up this bag we need this
don't mess up this bag if you think
about it if the Nintendo can now run
through the cloud with an extra chip
that's inside you could have the same
the same console the OLED same console
with an upgraded uh Cloud chip inside or
whatever something very minor
and it could play Call of Duty
what did you it can't do it now but now
if you can do it if it's able to do that
because my phone can play Call of Duty
so why can't my switch right so
if if the Nintendo switch can play all
these games all these third-party games
and this is what they was lacking
third-party game support Microsoft just
gave that to him in the back Signed
Sealed Delivered gave them to him in a
bag and told them listen this is how we
can work this thing over here but you
got to get your homeboy over there to
get on board because he's over there
talking crap over there with Google in
these dudes so Nintendo said who Sony
the dudes that try to finish us off the
dudes that snake that's in the back with
the square deal yeah
so they said okay they was holding on to
that because they back see their back
door Sega Sony backdoor Sega and knock
Sega out boom Nintendo was sitting there
they tried to do the same Flim Flam move
on Nintendo and back door Nintendo with
the GameCube I mean I really don't I
don't know that that happened that way
what we do is we sit on the hill we Sony
we sit on the hill so we watching
Nintendo and Sega fighting down there so
we see we see Nintendo getting the best
of Sega so we just sniped Sega
[Laughter]
okay
I have at it with Sega Nintendo right
all right so
they said Sony's doing this so what we
need to do is we need to go and back
door uh Sony
they sitting there at the Congressional
joint they all come inside it's only
thinking they're feeling really good all
right so we got a video Nintendo's hits
and we already know now Nintendo going
rock got uh these dudes over here oh 10
cent 10 cent mess with us we all go oh
so you thought somebody came into the
room over confidence it was it was good
okay we all our snitching stuff isn't
playing all right so we got our phone
and then dudes turn gunny on them yeah
nods those dudes right over there today
um we go inside with them we signed a
contract what you mean you sound a
confidential agreement with my man so
you know you think that the video threw
sodi off yeah it threw it yo it threw it
off because the whole big problem is the
cloud stuff oh so this if if these dudes
don't got a problem with it Google don't
matter state of your dead you know
what's crazy shout out to just good if
stadium was alive so most likely they
would have benefited from the deal for
Microsoft
you know the individuals that you're
dealing with so they don't have them
stick around now the Divergence thing
the thing is separating uh Call of Duty
from the deal
what are you telling me what to do with
my money
like you're not gonna do it you stop
acting like you really got power though
see this is the funniest thing I want
y'all to really look at it how the hell
you gonna give deals on something you
don't own
um
that's impossible right you can't go get
contract to nobody how is Microsoft
given a contract 10 years for Call of
Duty and we don't got it yet you're
stupid if you're not looking at it it's
already a done deal this is just pop and
circumstances okay this is just theater
this is just making sure dudes get the
proper overtime at their job because
everybody want to get their palms Greece
billion come across the table and say
how can I get some of that there's
nobody out here not one of you dudes
right now can tell me something that
y'all can sell somebody else
and you don't own it
so when I saw giving a 10-year deal I
said oh that's in the bag I said y'all
just y'all gave Sony a 10-year deal shut
up but what Sony is like because all
right
in Europe they have a 80 20 split Sony
has the uh the majority of the Monopoly
out there that's the battle that's a
Battleground that's a home turf oh yeah
that's what you're right because they
they killed you he was in the streets
out there yeah Jim killed off Japan and
made the EU the Battleground
so he strategically placed all the
people he know all the friends everybody
out there the world out there is
PlayStation who said who said I just got
to give up I told her Barry everybody
was like crying Ryan and being
disrespectful uh one lord said there's a
reason that man Rose the power and you
can't tell me he ain't got influence in
his home turf but good too but that's
that's what it is right now think about
it this way if Sean Layton was still in
place
none of this would be happening because
they were weak in Japan and they would
have been weak in the EU they wouldn't
have the ties in the EU to put this deal
up and have this collusion going on
right so yeah yeah it's collusion you
don't you don't want to lose your 80
stake that you have over there you know
right now with one game it can flip on
its head you did it with Final Fantasy
one game
flip Nintendo on his back like a turtle
that one game
seemingly buried Nintendo and gave uh uh
Sony the opportunity to become number
one to fight they fought you don't want
Microsoft to have that same go because
think about it this way right they don't
care if you got a Call of Duty over
there they don't care if it you got it
in PlayStation Plus yep please they will
want you to put in a PlayStation Plus
because you know what you have to do you
have to give them a bag
for putting it for for lost sales or or
projective revenue of that game they
will go back to projected revenue from
last year and you will have to pay that
bag at potential loss so you paying that
bag for them to put it in PlayStation
Plus and then you still got to pay them
for 10 years this ain't a are we giving
it to you we ain't giving you the
opportunity to pay us
you have the your adulterated
opportunity to give us money they put
you on that's like someone be coming to
your house and giving you a lease that
you got to pay them for 10 years how
stupid is this and they fighting for
this nobody but kick in their defense
they they getting free money for Call of
Duty as it is just being on the platform
right you know it's over it's over you
see they don't want to make Microsoft
Strong by paying them how could you
imagine
I don't even think that's the money I
think it's just the bargaining chips you
know when that 10 years Dale is up the
amount of mar like especially if Call of
Duty goes up from where it is the amount
of you know
influence in the amount of bargaine
chips that Microsoft would have over
Sony oh you like that billions you make
off us a year what you want what what
what what what how much you want that
money like
Microsoft
won it over there please have it over
there you're gonna buy it they're gonna
purchase it's fueling their war against
the same individual so could you imagine
me and you in a war
and I'm running low on bullets but your
check came in so I'm able to buy more
bullets
thank you thank you for financing my war
game
strength is
is fine when they're giving money to
Activision right and and blizzard oh
good we can give them money because they
not they don't have a console they can
put us out of business they just helping
us they're giving us good we got a good
game over here we the leading proud
platform on the marketing deal we
control a narrative people think Call of
Duty only resides over there when that
changes and is in Game Pass you're gonna
be like why should I spend 70 to 100
when I can just go over the Game Pass
Mass Exodus is going to start happening
that's why they call it bike so I was
like yeah Call of Duty
it's the deal is done
they can have a conditional deal
his 10 years on the Brooklyn Bridge
but if you plan to order it you can have
something conditional in place before to
give to give to give people who walk
across the bridge confidence that you
not gonna snatch the bridge and go come
again
that's not how it works out here
you negotiate after you acquired it you
can't because
my bridge and then you'll be like all
right everybody for the Bronx can't use
it I got this i got this
so you tell me you're going to
dealership you don't know if your your
application has been approved but you
telling people and inside the dealership
I could take you I'll drive you home
yo I got you you oh you need a ride I
got you
I needed it right that you gonna drive
me home after that
you got the car
so that's BS you offering rides you own
the whip stop it
and that nobody split the deal the 70
billion ain't nothing splitting and we
ain't giving no three billion this thing
ah this was a tough one hell no it's not
gonna happen this is the best thing to
happen right now it's watching Sony
squeal and squirm but
nobody's talking that we need this
Activision deal to go through because
Activision is a horrible Place nobody's
talking that oh what happened to the
staff members then nobody's talking
about the woman that unalived herself
there the Microsoft is bringing better
conditions nobody's talking about that
all you dudes is always worried about
all Call of Duty you gonna hack Call of
Duty so what you worried about no what
you really worried about and this is the
fear of it you don't care about no none
of those people there you don't care
about none of the conditions you're a
selfish individual all y'all really want
is to make sure that Microsoft don't get
no games and get no leg up on you that's
it it has nothing half of y'all don't
even play Call of Duty and don't tell me
that y'all like Candy Crush it's all
about making sure that Microsoft don't
make you an app because you know closer
and closer in this generation more so
than any generation you see your
mortality that goes out to you media
people right now they gotta play nice
are you implying yeah they've been
certain people been exposed by how they
feel yes yes because I've been wearing
this red for a minute for a certain fake
dragon
let's be nice
yeah listen listen Game of Thrones
somebody has said something slick a
while ago okay was it wasn't addressed
directly to you yeah yeah
fair enough it was a while ago before
you went on vacation fair enough yeah so
you're good sir you got your bars you
got it out of your chest I'm fantastic
that we we we officially know who's got
who who's on what team okay right but
why when the paperwork come up
they told them Yo um we suspended y'all
to come to the court and to show you uh
why are they backing up
why is Sony ain't giving the paperwork
Oh you mean about the end information
why aren't they showing the actual
numbers in the paperwork the show
because a lot of you guys be talking
Sony is number one we know this Sony is
number one in sales Sony is number one
in console sales Sony is number one in
game sales God of War sold I don't know
3 billion copies in two days
why isn't none of that same energy being
used over here yeah one second a week
Texas lead we're gonna give you a
warning I see you really in your
feelings but if you keep on you're gonna
be a body it's gonna be off with your
head so this is the last water bro you
know as I see the moderators on your
head already so shout out to the boss
but if you are too emotional because
just because you disagree with somebody
and you're disrespectful we will get you
out of here so it's the last one and
thank you
you Texas will be linked out of here
let me get this fresh kill right quick
thank you thank you no doubt anyway so
we got it that's about it anyway so look
um it's me so uh yeah look it's a lot of
information
um at the end of the day
this was this is there's some
grandstanding good you know what I'm
saying there's a little grandstanding
but look I I think what's Happening Here
is Microsoft is looking at what is
considered the harms that people are
saying and then trying to address that
and um what I feel is the Nintendo thing
we knew about right we already knew
about the relationship I think King is
on it as far as you know kind of feel
foreshadowing they was they had they had
a nice relationship with the switch on
the back of the um of the infamous desk
kind of thing and um you know to me it's
all about okay how could we show that we
are not trying to take this thing for
ourselves we're going to put it on more
platforms than it ever existed before
but I have to admit the Nvidia one
opened my eyes that was the one that
when I looked at it and I'm like okay
one of the things that I really feel
that the CMA you have to see all these
regulatory bodies have against Microsoft
that is legit is you you potentially
dominating in a nascent Market a market
that's new it's emerging and we've got
to be real like Azure is outside like
Azure the infrastructure is really large
you know what I mean and now that
Google's kind of out of the game right
them having theirs get those games on
that service that you kind of have the
most of could be in my opinion view as a
harm in that space and it may be
difficult for anybody to compete in that
space
I just want okay how is this different
me and you go into a battle and you pick
a shield and I pick a sword okay right
and this is what happened with Sony and
Microsoft Microsoft decided to pick
Azure Cloud I know where you're going
and Sony decided to pick up and they
said guy kind of failed okay right and
they did this right
Sony right now
is 100 alone in the console VR space
okay right not talking about uh quests
I'm sorry I'm doing the concert so you
like yo where's the where's the energy
for you're not allowing nobody to
compete that's what you're doing well
it's not that okay what you doing is
that everybody's business model is
singular on today self okay okay
so Microsoft is not precluding uh Sony
from jumping into that space actually
they help them in that space
they give them access to the cloud right
so they have always been inclusive with
Sony it's just the fact that Sony wants
to be exclusive to Microsoft they want
what you got but they want to be
exclusive no no no no no
we want to be above it all right you
understand and you try to say it's a
double standard these words aren't
really the truth is not really being
told okay Microsoft said from the
beginning we have no problem with giving
you any games correct
right now new IPS that sounds totally
different right Legacy games cool
ducking still continue because y'all
built the fan base over the Cinemax yeah
why would we do why would we take games
away from people that have been enjoying
this thing yeah that's wrong
but if we make a new IP we spend 70
billion we should have that that fruit
inside our ecosystem the ecosystem has
to grow overhead but we're not gonna
stop making Call of Duties I just it's
just hypocrisy that you know places has
a monopoly in the VR spacing console and
nobody is screaming I'm gonna tell you
right now I'm gonna tell you why and I
know where you're going because I at one
point was like yo how come they you know
me I'm for the violence
if you
buy something I feel you could do
whatever you want with it if you buy
exclusives I feel so these models you
could do it I don't have a problem I've
always been consistent I do not have a
problem here this is the difference I
had a great talk with great whole glow
about this because I was confused I'm
like why do I feel I was kind of going
with you like why is Microsoft held to a
different standard in this case but the
difference literally comes down to bro
money
and once you talk 66 what is it Billy
where we at because I even said I had
this shout out we had him on Duke one
time ultimate and I said okay let's say
the deal goes through now like yo they
gotta stop right because you know bought
66 Bill and Microsoft's good and I was
like you know that proclusive they can't
buy a Sega right they can't buy another
publisher and hope he's like no and I
was like well why like you know what's
the difference it's the same thing with
you know when you say like how come no
one's screaming that's only bought
bungee right Millions versus but once
they hit a certain threshold that's when
the flags go off that's when so again
it's not about you know fairness and
apples and apples it's really just about
the scope of it and that's when the FTC
jumps in well that's when everybody
wants bread yeah you see 66 billion come
across the table and you have problems
paying the mortgage
I need overtime we need the whole
we got to scrutinize this
look at the end of the day you know I
thought the Nvidia thing was very
interesting because again Saul said it
great you know I'm gonna be real with
y'all like I've used G-Force down shout
out to God too it is amazing I use it
for all my Shields and bro I'ma tell you
right now the latency like it's low key
it's 490s in there that's born in the
series you know series on series X so
you got that you know that the platform
is great now you're putting
Xbox games not you know what I'm saying
on that platform almost in like a steam
type Style on a on a competing cloud
service right so to me that definitely
helps their argument that they're not
trying to control the space until your
point but oh okay they're still gonna
get their bread you know what I'm saying
so that that to me was like the ultimate
okay we're playing ball we're gonna show
you that I think that was really big as
far as the Nintendo thing the only thing
is the key statement is they was like
they announced a 10-year deal to
Nintendo platforms
so because let's be real in my opinion
you talking fully featured Call of Duty
I'm sorry switches it's not happening
like that's cute that's cute Brad like
that that's cute by yourself good words
yeah that's verbage like you're not
getting that last Call of Duty looked
absolutely amazing on the series s or
little man you know what I'm saying so
like to bring that down to Integra fully
featured and then with the online
situation with Nintendo
comes in right it's either two things
it's either one they're gonna do because
we know Nintendo has been playing with
Cloud on some level control was on cloud
and I always told people I was in the
room that E3 when control got announced
and remember control was for next-gen
consoles at the time I was like what is
Reggie feed somebody doing in here yeah
that's what Reggie had to shoot his
whole deck they told me not to get close
but they're ready they didn't
assassinate me for trying to come in so
they they I was like yo why is he in
here and at the time I didn't realize
that I'll look back in retrospect they
were already working on a cloud suit
solution to get Next Generation games
onto switch platforms so it's either one
we're gonna go to Cloud right two let's
be honest we just talked about switch
recently they're towards the end of the
life cycle tears of the Kingdom seems
like they'll be the swan song Maybe
potentially for the first time the sales
are now evening Out PlayStation is here
you got that so they we have to admit
you know Microsoft and Xbox's Xbox
Nintendo been very cozy lately right so
in my opinion you can't tell me that
they may not have any inklings of when
that new Nintendo platform may come out
right so if there's a new Nintendo
platform that has a little bit more
robust features maybe you're better at
the same time Call of Duty you never
know we're thinking they have been
rumors shout out to Nintendo game gang
you know they've been they've been
rumors that it is actually time whether
it be a revision or a full upgrade so
that's where I got with it and um yeah
we're just we're just gonna have to see
what happens but I thought for them you
know this is this is a big for them to
put up statement again we're going to
see if this thing still gets blocked
we'll see how this thing plays out but
uh I I again we're tired of the activism
but I thought it was a substantial
enough thing that we have to talk about
it and then we'll see if this is enough
to uh satiate the regulatory body so
that's all I got anybody else before
760 plus inside the room yes and only
290 something likes please let's go
let's go let's go with that yes please
like and say that rare animal which you
already know the Red Nose Panda
Rudolph Panda yeah
basically say that they was like in the
deal too yeah well that's what I'm
talking about 10 cent was inside the
room this is nobody's objecting to this
nobody but Sony is sitting there talking
about this is bad
you know that hurt us
yeah yeah hit the like button save a
griffin on Harry Potter yes yes you got
to do that we got to do that attic out
here killing Griffin
good time all right we got
put the crust in the chat for the very
first Super Chat from Sean Mason five
dollars shout out to Sean the homie uh
Sean I I think hopefully we'll see you
at PAX East he said yeah he told me Toby
straight up to that face he was like yo
I'm okay so yeah get a homie hug it was
good to see him it's good to see him up
and about you know last last year was
not an easy year for him so yeah to see
him up and about is great
um we got God Emperor Sofa King two
dollar Super Chat Sony is on life
support damn no okay yeah yeah well I
mean
here we go well future prognosis
this is this is yo this is the moment in
time when you look back and say this is
what happened to you we didn't know
really how big the the Final Fantasy VII
well we we did know because it blew our
mind because we still had the um next
gen Magazine with the uh unreal uh the
ultra Nintendo Ultra uh 64 uh Final
Fantasy in there we still saw the demo
and then it was just the next E3 Sony
came in swooped that with a totally
different looking game but it was no
Final Fantasy and that really swayed
your decision in purchasing that's they
became a real fundamental threat in
Japan
if if and I want y'all to look at it if
Call of Duty is mainly played in Europe
if the sales is there just look at the
sales I don't know yet
that's a huge threat because that's
taking the battle right to their home
look we it's like addict said you know
we we can't minimize that's why I was
interested that they were like no we're
not investigating they call it because
we know what Call of Duty can do and
that's the Casual market and then you
have that brand like you said that brand
Association you have a series s you have
a digital console it could shift the
needle there's no doubt now I'm not
going to say automatically that makes
them but but if things turn around I'm
with you King that could be a signal
because again you have literally the
number one most you know Legacy dominant
game in your service you're going to
improve the subscribers to your service
and that's Microsoft's end game that's
what they want to do so and it may
lessen I have to admit that may lesson
people going to play Call of Duty we
have to admit that right that that's
just you know Common Sense
yeah okay hold on a second then we have
Robert we have Robert Keller two dollars
super chatswitch coming in hot running
Halo and gears at 10 FPS
I said just Just Call of Duty for that
right now yeah exactly we'll see we'll
still see yeah we need to talk about
that way they said Xbox games
and not and now again for the streets
they try to make it I think Biz got
ahead of it was like it's only Call of
Duty right now there's no other game for
switch per se now first switch Yeah
other stuff yeah yeah and we have
eternal should die 10 super chat this
goes hand in hand with the Michael pacta
prediction last year on the RDX podcast
he said PlayStation is doomed and
they're going to cease to exist in about
10 years is Microsoft 10-year offer is
it safe to say is it safe to PlayStation
I spent that way before you Mr Patrick
thank you though
then we got Stitch remember for two
years five dollar Super Chat by the way
it seems very apparent now that the
relationship between ABK and Sony is not
going to end well if this falls apart
we did talk about that man it would be
if if the deal got blocked
you can't tell me and Robert don't get
go take don't get his golden parachute
and and this but once you start messing
with the big money that relationship
will be interesting tomorrow this is the
thing but didn't they say didn't they
say if it doesn't happen he's probably
staying this there was it was rumors
maybe it's rumors he's staying
listen he's gonna stay there to hate on
Sony for the rest of the day it will be
very interesting when it was gonna be
like I could be on the Bahamas right now
I don't know bro
right that that's what is there going to
be some sort of result there I'm not
saying that the relationship will be
like oh we're gonna rip it off
PlayStation I'm saying that there's
going to be bitterness there that are
like look you guys are still going to
get our game because you gonna pay us
for that money but you ain't getting the
marketing anymore you ain't getting
anything extra anymore because you cost
us 69 billion dollars like it's not a
little bit of money uh you know sure I
think eventually they can repair repair
that relationship but it's going to be I
would say if this doesn't go through
PlayStation's gonna have a lot of
headaches with Activision until this
change of leadership there yeah and
remember if it doesn't go through
there's still a contract in place so
they still will be getting that
marketing back for whatever
place right now but they haven't been
returned to phone calls since then
it's like we're we're laughing but like
I I I'm serious like like here's the
thing even on
multi-billion dollar corporations like
that that still ran by Petty people yeah
if you cause people billions of dollars
over nothing because at the end of the
day like it would be different if it was
something significant that's stopping
this from happening like like there's
like lots of deals that's in place
between Mike uh between Sony and
Activision Mike Sony is stopping this
off of their own personal interests and
they should but you're gonna have but
you know regardless you still have the
consequences of that and I would not be
surprised if there are people there
because what was funny is this isn't
going to affect the people that are at
the bottom because they weren't really
getting cashed out anyway these are
gonna affect the people that were making
the decisions for Activision yeah yeah
well for sure for sure yeah we got to
see we got to see how the Fallout
happens either way like I said if it
does get blocked like you said what
happens you know Robert kotech still in
charge sorting relationship if it does
what happens you know what I'm saying
how's that going to play out it's it's a
lot we hopefully we're getting closer
it's the never ending soccer but yeah on
this road to E3 where are we at
um yeah
I'm talking about at the goals that we
hit what um
yeah I said 43 right now I'm looking at
it
I'm talking about on the sword
yeah that's what I just want to try
you'll see it I see it no I'm talking
about where okay so at uh 43 what did
they get what oh you're talking about
they get like the graphics right right
right Community stream yeah we owe them
a community a community stream and I
think uh the problem QA podcast yes the
problem was is I I want to combine both
of them together do like an hour hour
the other uh but uh Cog was traveling
this weekend like there's just no way we
could have done it this year
yeah no doubt no doubt let's continue
yeah I want to know because I'm I'm
looking at the you know the the road to
packs and you know they're helping us
achieve our goals for sure no we're
going to get that straight again I was
traveling and then me and Adam didn't
get a chance to talk we'll get the
graphic with the sword put lead the
actual individual
um Milestones that the realm has hit and
what we owe the realm for that so good
call out
next we got Tom from Toonami five
dollars with the chat and video was
literally the boltons at the Red Wedding
taking the deal
that's fire I like that Nvidia looked at
Jim and said Microsoft sends Erica yo
absolute your attic has to dig up right
now so we're close to 50 so 50 we get
retro game with the Lord so we already
got past a 25 Mark we got the round
table podcast coming about 50 we would
get retro game with the Lord
we're very close and for the love of God
I've played enough retro games make one
of the people that play retro games
Millennial place
and then we got yeah baby father
solve is Right Xbox is for the streets
it's pushing forward into the future
PlayStation will win the console battle
but the gaming War continues Xbox
Warriors gotta accept it
okay so and this is the reason why I
believe they numbers on sales and
consoles is for gazing
when you go home you turn the console on
they said like 20 of these joints aren't
being turned on so what's going on like
what's the real what's the real deal
with these things
I don't know what who's hoarding them
where they hiding them where they
stuffing them at pause I'm just saying
we can't trust these dudes we can't
trust the numbers that they put out we
can't even trust their words because one
day they tell you that a game ain't
coming to the the PlayStation 4 and then
they turn around like hey it's available
on the PlayStation 4. you just
we wonder why we're like what is it yes
yes this is literally
it has nothing to do with these guys
these guys don't rep these dudes like I
do anyway
so we have tempura five dollar Super
Chat hopefully we get a new Switch that
won't make Zelda look like DLC oh whoa
uh and I know you're gonna come for me
and say hey King is this DLC no it's not
then we got Stitch member for two years
five dollars for chat question should
Microsoft give the same deal to Sony if
they don't sign the current deal and the
merger happens
so no they get Popeye biscuits
biscuits with no milk
too right and Sony still didn't yeah
yo oh the super chats is wow you only
get one year and we'll see you every
year like a report card
see where you at let's see where you at
you're on the naughty list Hey kid
continue and they're not giving you
there we go we got ladies saying fifty
dollars my contribution to Pax 2023
shout out to lady thank you so much you
switch it back
continue okay thank you sir so shout out
to ladies saying oh salute 50 bucks to
our our packs fun appreciate it thank
you thank you blessings thank you and we
got yeah baby father five dollars chat
King needs a job at Xbox marketing he
does a better job than most of the folks
over there at selling dreams
[Laughter]
don't you
[Music]
let's go there we go
we get something geek
why is Sony scared
so I'm just for the streets
because you know they all over there in
places Sony don't want to go to afraid
to go down the valleys
so here we go yeah okay we'll talk about
that with the psvr
um and we got some crest of the chapel
Lord bronze Mandingo McDon
there you go put the crest in the chat
there we got Joe refko AKA flame two
dollar Super Chat your car got his
hashtag just one moderator band I'm dead
that's how you gotta get a fresh kill
every day look man I get it you know
what it is is that they get so mad with
King and it's just like yeah
they feel it and it's just like bro you
ain't gotta spam the chat with 70 000
Z's all this other nonsense that's all
just keep your feelings together I
didn't even see it oh I saw it let's go
bro when you was talking young man was
having a connection
see I'm like yo you spamming my guy like
so I had to get about it it was a fresh
kill I'm sorry off with your head you're
doing too much I say just bothering me
on Twitter
but you know what's funny is with grow
big they feel is that but it's like like
when you gotta type every second yeah
yeah you that's emotional damage like it
ain't that serious bro it's the king is
he's
he's down don't you tell me to calm down
I'm gonna put G azeed here all day and
tell him that King is fraud and then I'm
like all right
I just dance with big dudes in here oh
yeah
you already know
yeah you you get off yeah bro like that
I'm like I see that this bed melted down
on a live show I'm like wow King is in
his head right now I love yeah let's
just be let's be civil people that man
was ruined or not and get booted
like I got no problem off with your head
that we ain't doing we're gonna be
respectful what it was is you just
telling people to shut up and all that
that's what he crossed the line yeah I
got him emotion he didn't take his meds
this morning
[Music]
should die five dollars Super Chat I
wouldn't be surprised if the Nvidia
implemented their Cloud Tech into the
next Nintendo platform since a lot of
rumors about Nvidia being part of it
yeah I mean they go with tea for two or
whatever the because team or two been
around forever so they go with the
evolution of whatever Tigger is uh yeah
and that would be crazy because again
the the possibility that G-Force now
Tech could be in in a place
console yes
didn't think about that yeah and that
relationship was really good yeah yeah
exactly
although although they I mean they are
kind of getting pissed with them already
because again they'll turn around and
walk away and go to AMD you know what it
is because you got to think about it
like Nvidia do they really want to be
manufacturing
one like chipsets anymore no only
Nintendo's like we gonna need a million
more of these like you know the money's
there I'm assuming they're charging them
even more now because of the fact that
they're on a different development
pipeline so that's just funny to me hold
on there we go oh brother hold on hold
that let me roll back a little bit
we got jumped a little bit
um we have JD gamer 20 Super Chat
current PS sales don't reflect the
underlying feeling in the community it's
only as vulnerable it's losing they know
it and they're scared Todd will just be
the first major Domino to fall after
that it will be a quick painful death
Jesus it would be a long drawn out there
I like to see like in karate movies when
they get kicked in the chest and they
flip around for a little bit
the extra extended thanks
argue to be twenty dollars two dollar
Super Chat it's a little to my brothers
have a wonderful Sunday you as well
appreciate it we gotta address this chat
real quick oh what's going on what's
going on guys relax relax first off I
saw someone tell Cog to shut up so King
can can preach can't remember who it was
no that was a joke that was joking it
was just a continued I know where you go
I know you got boy I feel like this Chad
just being a little too surprised it's
just a little it's just two people
thing was jokes but it's just like like
relax guys it's games it's video games
but like we we this is all about just
talking about stuff you guys don't got
to go at each other you can playfully
joke yeah but I will be looking at the
chat because you're playfully joking and
mine are two different things exactly
it's just we're keeping good respected
shout out to Tom Henderson in the chat
hey Tom hey Luke still got your eyebrows
there we have let's play with each
other's joysters
retro games with the Lords does that
mean I can play naked twister with
something
[Applause]
moving right along
[Laughter]
we got plans
moving along
20 Super Chat we can't continue to use
the old metric to predict the future of
a changing Market that's a good way to
go out of business just ask Blockbuster
Circuit City betamax and every other
loser that that ever has been this is
this is facts though this is a factor
gotta gotta evolve at some point and we
got hold on I got Junk but we got a 150
Super Chat from The Gamers DMZ thank you
so much much appreciated much love for
the time the Lord's invest in the show
this is organically grown catch it
absolutely King sadly politics in my
opinion will kill the Microsoft APK deal
as my tweets have said catch your show
later this evening thank you brother I
appreciate it politics
from JD gamer that was uh missed you
want me to get that real quick yeah the
kid which one the the old metrics thing
I just heard that yeah he spent 150
dollars
and I'm gonna say uh to you your point
is valid I'm also gonna tell you that um
sometimes we see what we want to see
right maybe you want to see that happen
maybe you don't I see nobody can give
you a 10-year contract on something
so my thing is when somebody says
something that confident with a chess
out you know sometimes you just gotta
look at me like nah that dude right yeah
that deal gonna do it and the deal's
gonna go through feelings yo
a lot of things is making a whole bunch
of sense now that I'm just thinking
about it Phil been hanging out with your
favorite rapper
[Music]
and every time he hang out with him
every time the Shelf says something it's
just been prophetic yo Odin did not tell
us Phil go get the job done because he
didn't think he can do it he told him go
get the job done because he know Phil
can get the job done tell me a job that
Phil went out to get that he didn't come
back big game hunting this guy's been
big game hunting with spoons and now he
got 70 billion dollars to go big game
hunting nah this is done deal there we
have it he went he yo he had a big game
hunting for baseball he didn't go get
some average baseball he went and got
your baseball
how about that day one he playing yo
baseball like he's paying 17 for I don't
know who this man is but I'm telling you
if he taking your joint you got the best
right
we could do king now we gonna get boys
in the chat bro calm down
if you truly want this deal to go
through 100 just bet against it with me
because you don't got a good record
going right now
I'm not betting against anything
don't don't try to insert yourself
which is the one you thought that I
missed out
um let me scroll up JD game or something
about JD games it was JD gamer we can't
continue to use yeah I read that okay
I'll just make sure I appreciate it
then we got Lord Metroid two dollar
Super Chat this is just video games it's
not that serious agreed brother I agree
thank you Lord this is somebody's last
four hundred dollars
that PlayStation was his last 400 man
and I'm telling him that he got a dead
horse
as a king said bring the smoke to him on
Twitter he wants all the exciting the
chat his last 400 don't you tell that
man how to feel
[Laughter]
so dear Sony you can be the winner at
console sales we will all have
engagements Sony can have Final Fantasy
will have all the Western RPGs and Tango
and eventually Sega PS can have GT will
have Forza sorry so
always objective JD gamer that's what
I'm saying like I mean
as long like you don't have to be Sony
at their own game but you you have to
deliver enough quality projects and
quality games to ignore their other
stuff
and that that's a hard thing to do which
is why I think you kind of do have to
beat him at their own game unless I
don't think you do unless the game
changes unless the game changes I think
you know Starfield hits like it's
supposed to uh you know all their RPGs
Fable it's like it's supposed to have
out and it's like it's supposed to Elder
Scrolls it's like it's supposed to like
I just named you potential Game of the
Year especially Elder Scrolls like
people think star field being an
exclusive is going to blow up wait till
you start seeing gameplay of Elder
Scrolls yeah that's gonna hurt right
because stuff was a new thing Elder
Scrolls is the thing that's like it's
quality though if the games like we see
how what when you have a quality game
like when Hi-Fi rush comes out and it
changes the conversation the key is
going to be quality if the games are
good that's all that matters and then
you have that service and I think I
think that's where I mean also would
beat them at their own game everything
they drop is the perception is quality
even if it's just like surface level oh
it's beautiful it's gorgeous just you
know hashtag just one third person
energy and it may be underlying isn't
the you know the tightest game or
whatever
um but it hasn't really been the case
right so when Cog talks about quality
that's what it is too it has to look the
part as well absolutely I guess to me
the high Rush came off the bench besides
Fable because we don't really know a lot
like I I don't see a vowed in outer
Worlds 2 not hitting because that's from
obsidian and they have a really really
good track record uh you know besides
Fallout 76ers was made by another comp
another team uh all of Bethesda software
Studios that either been gaming of the
year or game of their contenders and
that that's literally four games right
there yeah it's execution that's what it
comes out yeah
execute them
stop it bro he said is execute them
Floyd Silva
then we have and we got JD gamer again
10 super chat Sony's out here as the old
guard and they were good really good
then somebody shows up with something
they haven't seen before South Park how
do you do it to softball but Xbox is not
just Southpaw they switch him back and
forth yes did they like Bud
oh I've never seen this before God went
South Pole City the Marvin Hagler
then we got robbery kill it
yo he's stupid Robert killer two dollar
super Jack King looking down at trolls
and laughing yes this is what king loves
to do very spicy he was trolling himself
because he didn't put it in color so I
don't see it
I would have literally just left him to
his old devices
then we have Alex
two dollars I mean I said Super Chat
which edition of DS2 lightfall 6449 901
24.99
I mean it just depends like I was like
what it depends if like when it comes to
lightfall like how committed you are or
do you know you're going to play every
season then you probably want to go
ahead and pick up the one where is the
Bush's Edition
silence
zero I got it right this time HUD zero
shout out to you sir Lord bronze put the
crest in the chat
then we have woden's Throne oh five
dollar Super Chat Xbox series X slash S
console shouldn't have issues to develop
games for like what was it with atomic
heart running better on PS5 is it the
API nope
um what it is is PlayStation renders at
a lower resolution oh boy uh Xbox is
rendering at true resolution so you get
this upskilled uh bucked up version and
you [__] up first it's not really
running how they try to say his running
so but a lot of these dudes got TCL
televisions too when they're running it
so okay their eyes are really
cataract-out
thank you King Foundry thank you
I like that you know being a digital
Foundry is made they you know they bones
off of you know the PlayStation 4
generation and showing the you know
resolution gate and all that other stuff
yeah it's racist right but this year
would I mean this generation anytime
Microsoft does do something we're so
close to get out of here before I didn't
know we was doing so well yeah yeah but
you messed up
any anytime Microsoft you know game
outperforms a Sony game huh
you don't hit crickets but that Hogwarts
or something anything
you know why it outperforms it on the
PlayStation and it doesn't outperform it
on the Xbox and I can take it honest to
God what's the honest truth you paid
seventy dollars
I'm gonna change the subject for that
that Hogwarts on that PC really what bro
the ray tracing do you see the
Reflections in on the ground and I'm
just like oh my God oh my gosh that's
level with it oh my my my you know
what's funny enough that stuff bothers
me like I it's there it's not there yeah
I'm a graphics for her best friend
that we have go ahead someone saw
something I was playing it's like man
that looks cool I didn't even notice
[Laughter]
then let's put the crest in the chat but
the upgraded membership to Lord gold Nam
Omar shout out to you sir appreciate it
absolutely man
then we have face 23 BK and why two
dollars Atomic Hearts is the same res on
PS5 and series X King got receipts for
you King yeah you ready ready is it or
is it uprised
is it or is it Dynamic scaled
I mean please tell me
I wouldn't know because my PlayStation
Don't Got Game Pass
here we go
which version did you buy
instead of talking about what somebody
else said what version did you get most
likely the place besides this buy here
most likely the PlayStation version and
if and if you talk about your play good
luck with your 10 extra frames get up
out of here you pay 70 for those 10
frames good luck with that
you know how much I paid for my friends
and you know what I'm doing the same
thing you doing get it for seventy
dollars and I did it for nothing
so go hate yourself don't hate on me
seventy dollars is the fee now you can
come over here and it's for free it's
called Xbox gaming pass and all you need
is one Buck that's what they talking
about one Buck Right you get one dollar
any I could pay one dollar to pay to
play the same game that you did for
seventy dollars
tell me why your math ain't mathing here
we go your math ain't doing the math
right they hustle it backwards baby
so he said get the game passes you don't
even bring that up don't talk to me
about a game outperforming another game
that's at 70 and I'm paying zero okay oh
that's what we do it now oh so we can't
compare that no I don't tell me about it
if it's okay if they both pay for
seventy dollars seventy dollars and it's
outperforming I'm upset
I'm I'm outside with you why is it doing
this but if I pay zero and all I did was
just hit install
now which car is he doing you see what
you're doing I see what you're doing
listen your card is mad at you all right
I didn't try to leave early in the house
what happens if Microsoft takes the
gloves off all Xbox game studios games
start hitting later this year publisher
of the Year again what happens when it's
three in a row yeah the possibilities
there like if it like addict said if
those games that are coming out dropping
the bangers and then they surprise us
with maybe like a sandwich at the end of
the years it's gonna be some kind of
year for sure I hope to God at the end
of this year we're not having man what
this year could have been yeah that
would be disappointing that would be a
lot of smoke it would be a lot of smoke
but they gonna get it then
we caught up oh wow
all right uh next topics it's a little
Baldur's game uh attic nobody set you up
on your top or you're good
uh part of me wants to set up but I feel
like I'll be too spicy you set me up all
right no doubt so look a lot a lot of
information uh ball just gate you know
first bit of information it's like the
Sony state of play that's when we saw
Baldur's Gate 3 had an actual release
date and this is where the information
you know got a little spicy coming to
PlayStation 5 and PC so it looks like
there was no mention of an Xbox version
which kind of you know set the to the
Streets On Fire a bit and then uh we got
confirmation
um from because I believe the talk
initially was you know oh there it is
exclusivity right that Sony has some
type of marketing but uh shout out to
larion man they jump right in front of
it you know it says that there is no
exclusivity deal um in the post share
that is subreddit they said Xbox players
we've seen your questions about it if
you can expect Baldur's Gate 3 on Xbox
we've had an Xbox version of bulgers
Gate 3 in the works for some time but we
have run into some technical issues
particularly with Split Screen Co-op we
are still working on an Xbox version of
bald Skate 3 but we're not yet confident
enough to announce it we don't like
announcing anything until we're ready
because we don't want to get people's
hope up until we're sure we deliver the
final statement there is no platform
exclusivity preventing us from releasing
Baldur's Gate 3 on Xbox day and date
should that be a technical possibility
the developer concluded if and when we
do announce future further platforms we
want to make sure each version lives up
to our standards and expectation so then
it then shifted to Twitter streets it
was really hot at that point that calmed
down but then it picked back up because
there were suggestions
and little man might be the problem so
this started to to Really ramp up and I
want to shout out the developer as far
as um his name is uh on Twitter Cromwell
he's from director of publishing of
larion Studios so what people would then
say Oh okay we know why it's it's
probably the series s and a lot of media
Outlets a lot of people you know ran
with it and you know I mean that was
based on the information provided at the
top so then he jumped in front of it and
say look couch Co-op is an RPG of this
scale is a technical hurdle full stop we
have hard-working teams who have a great
deal working on couch Co-op across all
platforms he said there's a reason many
RPGs don't do it development hurdles are
normal this always has bigger big ones
so he's been responding to everyone who
says the series s is the problem to say
this is a technical issue this has
nothing specifically to deal with he's
been kind of jumping in front of that so
and basically the last point I'll say is
he said um
that you know I guess they're really
fighting for college Co-op because most
games don't do it he said believe me
when I tell you there's people are
working on this with care they're Best
in Class they're solving unsolvable
problems and then he said we uh thank
you for letting us know that the console
audience cares about Boulders gate three
UK weekends to start a beautiful
relationship so he wanted to he seemed
very aggressive on Twitter that the
statement of the series s b little man
being a problem he seemed to be wanting
to jump in that so that's been a little
bit of the contention the debate and of
course it's Lucy addict this is your
topic you had a lot to say on Twitter
when the news first broke that many
thought was a PlayStation exclusive
and me at that time you know we have
seen Sony pop in in the back door like
this is mine multiple times I just
assumed it was one of those times uh you
know it does look like that that isn't
the case here and it might be more of a
you know a limitation on the Xbox series
s uh you know I I I'm willing to bet
it's that because to me if the PS5 can
run and why can't the extra on it and if
the X can't run it then there's
something else going on which I don't
think that's the case because I highly
doubt one can run and not the other so
to me the only difference between the
PlayStation Arc uh ecosystem and the
Xbox is the s
uh because you know they got that
mandate where you have to have it run on
the series s to you to release something
unbelievable what he says that basically
what he said it's not you know you don't
necessarily buy you're not buying it is
what you're saying yeah I think that's
PR they don't want to upset anyone at
Microsoft uh you know they don't want
the heat being on them for anything then
they get you know uh this this developer
is a good developer they've always made
good games uh you know a Divinity
original sin you know I love those games
and you know it if the S is doing it
then it's like one of those things where
it sucks you know um I I have to see a
little bit more like
I just I guess to me the only other
thing that would make sense is they were
working on the PS5 before the series The
X version right but then once again like
does that really make sense because you
don't see other games having this issue
where they gotta delay the Xbox version
because they had to get the PlayStation
version out like to me it's got to be a
limitation issue and the only difference
between the two variables is the S the
only because it seemed like they got the
PlayStation 5 one running just fine
no I get I get where you going I guess
the only question I have for you is what
do you say for people who say it can't
be the series that's because it's coming
to PC also and there's less
configurations worser than the series s
on PC and that it's still coming to
those platforms
well it's been in those platforms for a
while like they're they're making these
current ports right now and sure there's
different configurations on that but
have you ever tried to play a PC game
under the recommendations yeah it's not
a pretty time it's not pretty at all and
we got to remember sometimes when we
talk about that it's like you still have
to when you're developing for a console
there's a certain level of Polish that's
kind of expected whereas when you're on
the PC side that's a good point all of
these all of these specs are tested for
not as thoroughly as a console release
right it it it's there's so much of it
on the PC that you can't possibly hope
to get every little thing when you're
when you're honing it to a specific spec
on on a console that's where again the
the smaller details of things not
working properly and exactly as you want
it to that's where it really comes up so
to me it is something that it could be
an issue that on a on a PC spec that's
similar to the S it's passable but for
the s per se is not right um so it you
know to me that's that's the thinking I
think
attic you finish I'm sorry I want to
interrupt you yeah it's just one of
those things where you know if it is the
s
I I low-key would have preferred them
just to leave the S out of the skew like
because I said it from the start you
know at the beginning of the generation
you know there weren't gonna be a lot of
issues but we've seen multiple times
games coming out in 30 and they had a
patch later to make it at 60. like it's
clearly s is an issue you know sure
there's some developers that could do it
well uh but it does look like a lot of
developers are having challenging issues
developing around the S to PS5 and the
series X
solve for your thoughts on Larry and
baldisgate first exclusivity not
exclusivity first series s people
blaming and now Laren really coming hard
at all media Outlets you know it's had
some very big happy going to people our
articles that says series that's in it
and say hell that's not true that's not
true that like I've never seen this
aggressively against it against people
with that yeah I mean you know it is it
it's it's again outlets editorializing
and sort of filling in the blanks
themselves and not you know kind of
stating it as
not stating it as fact right but it
comes off you have to be clear when
you're like this is an opinion piece my
opinion is blah blah blah blah blah and
and so when it's coming off like that's
the Assumption and everybody's kind of
saying it you got to be clear about what
you know it being an opinion
um but I agree with addict I said you
know it just seems like when you're
developing for two different skus and
again the issue that we've talked about
with us it's challenging and the ram
issue on the S is is challenging right
the GPU stuff the CPU stuff is well the
GPU stuff obviously it's it's lesser and
the CPU stuff being faster helps with
that type of bottleneck but if it's not
a game that's CPU bound the bottleneck's
not gonna matter right
so it's just one of those things where
when you're when you're developing like
that
it is going to require more work and we
talked about this last time when they
when the issue came up about the series
that's just like well it's it's the
amount of work that goes into it
sometimes when you see these arguments
about the series this is the albatross
whatever the work that has to go into
making it good is the albatross it's
it's the fact that okay how much is it
going to cost us to put the work in to
get it to where we need it to get is it
worth it to us and sometimes that's
that's the discussion and it comes off
as oh this this machine sucks no it
doesn't suck it's just work you know
what the interesting part is to solve
like normally in the past when the they
because it's all about time they can
easily they can get this game running on
the S it's just
and the time to get this game running on
uh the S because we don't even know if
it's that uh but the time to potentially
get this running on both consoles is
going to take more time than it is for
the game to come out so obviously it's
been pushed back but it's just like it's
interesting because like die Dying Light
too I remember that that was 30 frames
on the console for like a month or two
and then they got the 60 frame patch
yeah normally they just dial stuff back
on the S to get it running but if it is
the s in this particular moment they
weren't able to do that so you know it
they're being very very adamant that
it's not the S I'm a question I think I
still think it's more of a PR thing but
if it isn't the S uh you know I just I
just hope the game comes out relatively
you know are we looking at like a
six-month delay are we looking at it
yeah I got an interesting question I
don't think nobody's ever
this generation let's let's have some
some real talk
do we think based on what we're seeing
now now granted to King's Point you know
not every port you know the series s or
X is losing like I would say let's just
I'll put up a theoretic I'm just going
by you know what I see anecdotally so
let's just say it's 60 percent
the series XS version runs better but
there's a 40 where the PlayStation 5
version runs Superior right what if I
want to ask you guys this the series X
and S is just hard to develop for in
general and the PlayStation 5 is an
easier entry point just from a
development store I mean remember we
come from the days of 360 and the
PlayStation 3 right you know what I'm
saying like I remember but that's the
ports being a problem
I remember 360 being the easier console
so do we think as much as kick saw you
know Xbox has been talking Power Talk
power talk what if it's a hard to
develop four comps that would be so
weird because again everything is just
splitting your resources between two
platforms yeah I think so I think I
think I'm with addict it just every
everything everything
after the Xbox 360 and the PS3 was is
this x86 base it's just easier across
the board I don't I again I don't I
don't know the ins and outs of it right
maybe we can have Jason Ronald on again
to talk about it or whatever absolutely
um but but but it is a thing where I
don't feel like these things are feel
like they're programmed like like PCS so
you can have that that sort of ubiquity
when it comes to the development
pipeline across all the platforms so I
don't it would be weird to me if there's
something there that's so bespoke
let's be real like we not we actually
there's been a certain Lord you know you
know talking about the console of the
PlayStation 5. it's unstable but what
lesson
he's the reason we're considered an Xbox
One
I Got You cake I'll let you get your
balls open I want to agitate you a
little bit so so but I think so let's
just say the weight of PS5 is designed
with the you know the CPU or the tech
you know the way it's fluctuating like
kicks it this is ideal for developers so
that they can just get to the to the
metal and boom it's a it's an easiest
and you throw that on top of a install
base that's already huh what you what
you going to develop for it could be I
mean we're gonna now right this year
this year oh we focus
what you did what you did real quick oh
you're about to cover me you focus you
focused
okay okay I gotta get it I think it's
it's this is one of the incidents like
look let's be real that s Works nine
times out of ten you know there's
certain games that they have to patch
later but for the most part they get
them working on both platforms I'm a
little concerned but the future how like
yeah the generations gonna go but as of
right now I would say it's not a huge
issue but it is a concerning raise your
eyebrow what's gonna happen two or three
years we're getting closer we're getting
closer to the point we're not seeing
back back Compact and keep it keep yeah
keep in mind
most of these games are coming out next
you know yeah and Mark certainly is well
designed console we sat here and we one
of our biggest streams is with King's
clouding walk 30s remember the ears what
if the Lord Cerny is the prophet that he
figured out the Next Generation battle
was won with the fluctuation in the SSD
and he had the superior console okay
what say you to that
oh
all right so you know like developing
for Xbox series X and X uh snx is uh
like reading War and Peace okay okay
you have a red worn piece a lot of you
you haven't had War and Peace but a lot
of you guys have read uh what is it a Dr
Seuss books
your Red Cat in the Hat
your red green eggs and ham right yeah
but a lot of y'all can't get through War
and Peace it's a thick book
so vrr
full rdna2 you know stuff like this
these are big words when you come to
developers right so a lot of these
developers is like all right well let's
get the one that we can get out to ease
this the fastest one right now the one
without all the bells and whistles let's
just get this one out you know um
because they have TCL televisions oh God
familiar with these Dev kits because
they're PlayStation 4 Dev kits
they just up
resched up I'm gonna shut up
just real quick I'll stop you for a
second Jonathan Roberts already posted
his uh IOP without context so oh he
already did it yeah we didn't even
finish all right
let me hit kick get out of this one
let them cook all they doing is giving
you up Res PlayStation
and it's really cool because what are
they doing has any of them used that
fast SSD yet has any of them did
anything that the PlayStation 4 cannot
do nobody can right it doesn't it
doesn't happen that way all right so now
we already know that the Xbox One is
gone
these Dev kits is what we're talking
about here series action X so a lot of
these developers say you know let's
handle this first but not even going to
talk about that let's talk about
Boulder's Gate just kidding because
we're not going to talk about the
unstable box and the PlayStation 4 is
really the real version in the
PlayStation 5 is just an up-res mess
that's all that is but we're gonna do
that we're gonna talk about Boulder's
Gate where was it I'm showing the state
of play right yes wasn't that a stadia
game
I don't know before it was exclusive it
was it was announced originally on this
on Stadium it was an exclusive was
exclusive but it was first announced it
was at the stadium reveal yeah it was an
announcement for nobody else right
right so when they did they showed you
Lauren has showed you
whoever announced first just to be
transparent uh that game is on Steam
right now Early Access
okay okay continue so
they showed it over there we didn't hear
about no series X we didn't hear about
no PlayStation 5 version okay okay
we heard that it was stadia exclusive it
was Stadium Windows yeah okay okay
this three repeats itself the shown on
the Sony stage so shut up don't tell
them that it's coming out for nobody
else
all right we giving you light right now
let us sell hours over here first let's
let us get our pre-orders here because
we ain't got no Game Pass we ain't
dropping no game pass so let's get our
pre-orders and stuff in first we gave
you light on our stage don't you say
nothing about Xbox okay
do you think that they might be using
the slips the the split screen is an
excuse to not say they sold marketing to
PlayStation like that but we don't see
the contracts right we we only we only
here you know you so you can tell
somebody
oh that's not true
you don't got to tell anybody the truth
there's contracts okay this is a need to
know basis and you don't need to know so
we don't believe in the development all
right no no what I'm not believing is
what you don't believe
right now they're quiet on it we have a
version we're working on it we're not
going to give you a date because we're
going to let Sony sell so if you're
ambiguous about the date and you really
want Boulder's Gate
you're gonna go get that PlayStation 5
because right now
that's the only thing that is sure the
Xbox One is unsure because they talking
about oh
the split screen is a problem now
you know the haters ran out there and
was like little man is the problem
because they want to kill the little man
a little bit he was fighting for his
life
he was on Kelly I'm fighting for myself
[Music]
and they'd be like yo he's the one the
little man like what are you talking
about I didn't even do anything little
man is fine okay all right so all they
do is render it at a lower uh resolution
listen the switch has done it all the
time so just lower it a lower resolution
get the games out right now they're not
going to talk about the Xbox version
because the PlayStation gave them light
on stage okay I believe if Microsoft
would have gave them light on stage you
would have heard about the Microsoft
version and the PlayStation versions
come later there's no technical issues
there's money issues
that's the technical
issues you can't talk about it and you
don't want to mess up the bag over at
Microsoft by saying yeah it's little man
you want to shut that down quick and
early as possible nah nah little man
ain't got no problem with this we got
split screen problems and that's the
only thing that we have so you're with
addict you would attic do that a little
bit it's the cash you got paid to shut
up you ain't got nobody telling you they
don't see the contract you got to tell
them show me the contract they don't
gotta show you anything and they don't
got to tell you a damn thing so
everybody's out here knows Sony don't
have exclusivity shut up you don't know
nothing you know absolutely zero just
because they said we don't have a school
they don't gotta tell you oh we
exclusive for sickness
if they have a six-month time
exclusivity and it takes them six months
to fix slices
I will say this though you
it's interesting to me that Sony's gonna
put that bread let's say they put that
bread down whether they did it then
whatever but it's interesting to me that
they're going after a western RPG okay
it just it's really interesting to me
like you see that you see the
machinations where it's like Microsoft
could have buy them they're gonna take
it because Microsoft has damn near
everything under this belt that's one of
the only uh Western RPGs that's like
really popular that they don't own that
they don't right they don't in some kind
of relationship with right choice good
choice it is a very good choice but the
fact that the potential is there that
there could be some deal that we don't
know about and it's some kind of
exclusive marketing it's just again it's
very telling to where Sony's mind is at
like oh hell no
we have to because again if you even
think about the type of game that it is
compared to if you if you if you assume
that the vast majority of PlayStation
heads are more jrpg heads right that you
know the final fantasies or whatever it
doesn't even feel like a game that
really fits in terms of we're going to
give you this money to get this
exclusivity or whatever it doesn't feel
like it fits on that platform as much as
a jrpg would so it's just very
interesting to me the thinking that yeah
we gotta we gotta we have to we have to
put this in light that it's it's on a
Sony platform and it's you know maybe
exclusive yeah
um no no it is that thing of like hey
we can't allow this this narrative to
get out of hand where all of these types
of games is Xbox games like it's not
gonna happen but who who can't allow
what narrative to get out of here who
PlayStation
the reason that
um
even though that might not be true it
might be true you have to you have to at
least say it's possible because of their
history that's the side part they've
been so like like very aggressive with
marketing and stuff like that I mean we
see Destiny where they they couldn't
even mention that the game was on the
platform okay we see time and time that
they have been very you know pushing
time and exclusivities past their normal
date locking down whole franchises to
the franchise like I don't know if it's
the s or it's PlayStation but the funny
thing is you know as much as I think it
might be you know some limitations with
the S at some degree it could easily be
the PlayStation thing because that's
just how they roll that's just how they
roll and to me it's it's just weird to
me just because when you look at it like
that's a crpg straight up that
PlayStation does not feel like the
platform that you that would be like
here take this money you're gonna be
here it's it's just and for them to be
announced on their platform coming to
the console that's what I'm talking
about times
you can't be you can't beat it
you know Sony said yo whatever you do do
not say that we got exclusive for any
type of months because we with the uh
you eat you know
yeah we can't be having that yeah
so what are we dating you but
we don't want nobody to know but in the
past In fairness
those conspiracy theories that y'all
talking about in the past you couldn't
even the developer couldn't even say
that an Xbox version existed the
developer is coming out full blast and
saying no y'all y'all good man okay this
is part of the deception what is
deception because they they told them Yo
listen you cannot say we got anything
exclusive right now we gave you light on
the stage
for a couple of months this is a bro man
handshake don't mess this up for me we
trying to get these dudes out the box
Don't You Buck up because the next time
we not gonna let y'all in we're gonna
it's not gonna give you no like this is
the thing I'm gonna read this I'm gonna
jump and read this last Super Chat from
Dave Ramos 2017 chat any games yet
confirmed Series S couldn't handle and I
think that speaks to the point of like
yeah it can handle it right yeah
it's just it's just a matter of time
like well even if it's the S this game's
gonna come out eventually but
but it's just you know the funny thing
is it could be either one of those it
could there's a variety noise it could
be something as simple it could be
something as simple as they had outdated
Dev kits that they got updated too late
the libraries the library oh man we all
know it's Sony y'all just don't want to
sing it so this is where your heart pump
cooler yo
see what we use that King don't believe
the dabs man I can just fight a bit
because it's like before according to
the conspiracy theory how many times has
a girl told you nah I ain't cheat
now she ain't got to tell you the truth
man listen all I've seen
all I've said is according to y'all
theory in the past when there was an
Xbox version right it wouldn't if there
was no Xbox version it wouldn't even be
allowed to even be talked about because
if the money exchange has like y'all
said right and they like yo don't you
you not even supposed to say that Xbox
even getting anything kind of like the
Final Fantasy 7 remake situation
but nah this is different the dev is
literally this is like when you hanging
out with you yeah go ahead I'm gonna
tell you it's just like this right you
got a girlfriend
but you hanging out with your cousin
hey y'all over there but she really
ain't your cousin you're gonna say who
what cousin is that and the girl go oh
you know the cousin from the Auntie from
over there
and be like see they doing it right now
they're doing the ball this game to us
right now and they don't they don't want
that so so just to clarify yeah just to
be transparent 100 you don't think
there's a shot in hell that this could
be anything on the technical issue you
think this isn't entirely I think it's
yeah I think you think mainly it's it's
marketing no it could be but I believe
that Sony is is more underhanded than I
do believe in technical issues
so if we're gonna balance the reasons
why this could be I'm gonna always shift
to us
all right so so I I listen I trust a
snake to be a snake
with a wild bangle snake
if you know what it is King like uh
because it took them a minute to respond
to that they called PlayStation like yo
you know they want to know a place like
dude we we right now trying to get that
College
third eye Lords are striking again
Miss Cleo Lords you're outside somebody
said how you got this number my thing is
my this is my thing [__] right my thing
is this if
why not like if you're confident that
there's no issue with this machine you
just announce it for Xbox as well right
that's right and that's that's the thing
about it right are you so so what
happens if they can't let's say let's
say it is a technical thing they don't
want to tell you and they can't get it
to run on the satisfactory form on the S
are you just not releasing it on the X
because because of this directive what
if they just a smaller Studio that has
the resources to develop one at a time
hold on you did say y'all did say right
that this game was a stadia game first
right then it shifted right and if we
talk in business what's the platform you
need to make
so now you do the PlayStation
right so if your resources are there why
can't it just be yo we just got the
resources to do this one at a time y'all
gonna get your joint when we get it to
the satisfactory State because again
they said technical issue and they say
couch Co-op hold on yeah I'll let y'all
cook
conspiracies
according to Google this company has
over 250 people as a 2021. fair enough
all I'm saying is when you shift
development if you come out for a
console or a platform that now no longer
exists you can't tell me that they
didn't have a whole bunch of resources
invested in stadia you still have to
shift right
but it was PC as well right so and PC
right a lot of configurations right and
you get places I will give you all this
I'm not full with y'all conspiracy but
y'all all the way the only thing I will
give you is yes if you're on the Sony
stage
yeah there is some level of you gonna
talk about us you not talk about nobody
else oh always I will give you that but
it's for the only reason why I think
this is different where it's like oh
it's all away with it is that they are
literally saying for the first time this
is what we didn't get from Final Fantasy
7 rebate bro we have an Xbox version yo
this is what's going on that's why I
believe it because if they would not oh
we don't have nothing to announce at
this time
no but but it was never no official all
the way and then when fans put the
pressure on like yo Final Fantasy where
you at the years up did you know when
you get that you don't have these are
the platforms that we're ready to talk
about at this time
that's what I know but that's what I
think I think it's a different
microscope going on right now but all
I'm saying is this right yes
Microsoft had a show this year and and
they showed it was very buttoned down
with what they wanted to do they didn't
want a game to come in to overshadow
Hi-Fi Rush right so Hi-Fi Rush is pretty
much
um stealth Drive boom thing but Sony had
a state of play right
now I believe that Boulder's Gate went
with whoever was going to show them off
in the best light give them that period
of time to sell I honestly believe that
there's a deal in the background
right and I know you said before there
was transparency in certain deals
certain deals you know people can go
through and they'll come out and say no
we are yes we are I just believe right
now there's an extra level of collusion
in a situation where there's eyeballs
being looked at people because Microsoft
right now don't want to say certain
things either Microsoft right now don't
want to do certain deals either okay so
there's too many eyes on this deal going
through and not going through and this
will be a very highlighted situation by
saying yo this is a highly anticipated
game that Sony has froze out of the the
a group of players that this is not a
first party game and they signed a third
party deal to keep it exclusive to their
platform for six to something months and
that will be a very good talking point
so I think Sony wants to avoid that and
I think they said you know what you did
to give us the light you did show us you
know um first and you put a good light
on the state of play how many people was
watching they put eyeballs on it how
many sales went up you know the bag was
dropped I just believe that we're was a
wink wink handshake thing but I I only
part y'all lose me is when the developer
comes out and says we are still working
on the Xbox version
like I just don't get if you have this
bag that was slid underneath why keep
mentioning that we got an Xbox version
we've been working on it for some time
they don't lose anything and they also
save face for Sony they didn't throw
Sony under the bus and they're like yo
we got this over here
you know what it is King they got that
version of they're working on until that
bag is slid under yourself
you know that TV show where where
they're trying to get the person with
with the on on death row call from the
government they said they're about to
finish they get the phone call they pick
up they're like stop
the bag don't finish the game
oh man let me see I guess and then
people are like listen to ABK asset okay
we'll see we'll see what happens the
victory contract is revealed it's just
it's kind of weird in and of itself that
they will get out in front of that right
at all and even talk about it this is
our last stop they're getting dragged on
Twitter
like yo why are we getting treated like
second-class citizens fam yeah
I get that but all I'm saying is they
literally responded to the pressure this
guy is outside every tweet tweets per
second tweets per second it's bad they
keep going at everybody I've never seen
that level of energy whatever
so sorry to derail this uh you know how
I said my theater is like whack and they
didn't get that cocaine back there tell
me how they close it after today
oh no that's crazy
yeah that's wild but anyway oh oh wow
okay yeah Jesus that's all I got that's
right but I'll let y'all cook today
[Music]
anyway well we got this yeah we thought
it'd be copy paste this last one
absolutely y'all up in the chat up in
the chat let's see let's see
okay ready to go we got uh Robert Kelly
Two Dollars Super Chat
little man not packing enough juice
yo let's see we ain't gonna look a
little man like that
I'm looking at what little man walking
with cut it out absolutely
I can't get Marlin wins
that's all you kicked no one gives the
the Lord walks early his props right
there ain't nobody giving him no no Bare
Bones Basics
PlayStation 4. easy to develop the
developers
this chat is wild
this is simple send the team get about
this gate looking good that's it that is
simple as that there ain't nothing wrong
with that because Microsoft would have
been sent the team all they would have
said was yo we're having a problem with
the split screen hold on let us send
some um people from the Coalition over
there because
Boulder's Gate don't look like it's a a
super intensive game oh damn
split the screen get out of here they do
a local co-op who do a local co-op there
yeah I know I saw they out of pocket
out of pocket ain't my man
[Music]
want to do let me break protocol for a
moment
let me play with cogs doing [__]
I'm spitting but I'm swallowing
this is this is a this is a family show
wow I appreciate you know the Lord's
love everyone this is the family show
you gotta relax yourself sir you gotta
relax yourself you gotta relax
I'm embarrassed for you
that's great
I'm about to get yeah you're gonna have
to check in for that
comments
she was like damn I missed it yeah
time let's move on please people brought
his own folks into the event
s
he's got like one of those voice boxes
not telling what you want here yeah
no
the holes left
who's talking history the battle makes
the hosting
he said he got him it's not what you
wanted
and then he presses it again where he
squeezes it
and then he squeezes it and it says are
you implying
he said also will you squeeze his tummy
are you replying it
oh my God
imagine the president
just one hand
Infinity oh my God yeah I got all this
sayings
boy's a legend remember for 38 months
Lord bronze looks like PlayStation is
Bucking up all over these gaming streets
shout out to Samsung this uh s23 Ultra
is fire and yes Xbox is the best box
Jesus
[Music]
put the crust in the chat but Lord
bronze back from the dead one shout out
to you sir appreciate your support
and we got JD gaming member for two
years five dollars Super Chat no worries
Xbox will be running through the back
door of many dabs and Publishers real
soon Sony has until the ABK deals ends
before the hammer drops
the little plushie goes
[Music]
I was disgusted
[Laughter]
right now
oh no you press this to stop read that
yeah
oh yeah Super Chat to back on track
let's go let's go yes let's get to that
we have it yeah I don't know yeah
thank you for making it right brother
thank you for making it right
maybe there really is an issue with the
split screen on the ass we'll see we'll
see
five dollars I remember for two years
there's a lot of features a feature
parody parody between the PS5 they can't
use the extra features on the Xbox could
be you never know
sorry Dave Ramos I read this one I could
have read this respect um
I was affected yeah we got Robert Kelly
people act like little man be like the
Saturn
what's going on here yeah hey chat let's
get mods let's get this guy out of here
cool off
we got top of two dollars five dollars
gray Hill incident marketing PS5 PC and
other platforms and other platforms
then we got pixel bit G remember for 38
months Lord bronze thank you sir how
many gamers on Mac the game is coming
day one the Mac great chat yo yo
see that's foul that's how you know the
bag was slick
the busted back that's what you do oh
man there we got Cali and brown member
for one month Lord silver on effort hold
on a second this thing scrolled over
damn on ff14 square and Phil said they
had a finished version that they went
then they went ghost don't underestimate
Sony
that's right exactly you already know
what time it is you put his luck with
his put his flag back down
sir
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
um atomic heart man what's going on
yeah uh so I got the player Thomas maybe
like three hours of atomic heart this is
the new game from the new developer uh
coming out of Russia mon fish
um it at first glance everybody look at
it and be like that's Bioshock and it is
it wears his influences on his sleeve
for sure um it's definitely Bioshock at
a look right when you start playing a
little bit more you realize it's
Bioshock it's Wolfenstein it's new
Wolfenstein it's Arcane games a little
bit right it's a little bit a little bit
of immersive Sim stealth stuff going on
um and I think as a first effort this is
really impressive to me again I'm only a
couple hours in but it's super
impressive to me so uh like General
overview
um so the game is essentially about uh
alternate history sort of Russia 1940s
1950s where uh basically Russia uh you
know scientists a specific scientist in
Russia has come up with something that
they call like a polymer right and
essentially it's something that you can
inject into your body right and this is
like a futuristic world right one of
those futuristic Utopia World War II
um they didn't well they they talk they
talk about the Nazis and then they they
talk about how they came out of it you
know they talk about atrocities like
there's this one scene where they have
like a monument and you see like you
know the the fake accomplishments and
stuff like that but in the intersperse
real stuff in there as well so coming
out of that war oh you read the war yeah
yeah I read the wall yeah so you coming
coming out of the war right it's like
okay the scientist comes up with this
with this amazing thing they supposedly
the Nazis put out some some crazy virus
that that kind of killed a whole bunch
of people and then post that the
scientist comes up with this thing they
they automate all of society basically
so robots are integral to the society
and they're it's funny because they have
you have different types of robots right
you have like these ballerina looking
female robots then the the general male
robot looks like a dude with like a like
a porn Like a Porn Stash like they all
have like these weird 70s porno stashes
is and and then you have like uh you
know robots that really look like
industrial robots these big bulking sort
of Hosting things right
and and so this is the games kind of
starts at this is the beginning so it's
not really a spoiler but basically this
whole polymer thing is going to become
sort of ubiquitous across Society now
everybody's going to have the chance to
inject themselves with this stuff and
become super smart immediately right
okay uh something happens and uh the uh
the the robots go Haywire because the
robot's got a little taste of that
problem and they're like oh yeah
yeah so you know a lot of Skynet type of
stuff happens right
so you play this uh you play this uh
this war veteran and actually I forget
his name but they keep calling him P3 so
it's the story of Phil Spencer
P3 yeah that's funny um so basically uh
the story about about this sort of
character and and and kind of it goes
into
figuring out exactly how deep the rabbit
hole goes where this Utopia is like most
utopian games where it's like it's not
quite what it appears to be and things
are really messed up in really messed up
ways
um kind of uncovering that so gameplay
wise gameplay wise when you look at it
again Bioshock you have you have uh a
sentient sort of uh
thing that's it kind of installed in
your left hand his name is Charles by
the way right okay and it's funny
because we were talking about hentai
tentacles yeah it's a Hentai tentacle
thing coming out of his in the game
you're playing continue exactly yes
that allows you that allows you to
basically as you walk around the world
you can collect all kind of stuff to
upgrade your weapons and the great
upgrade your abilities so the abilities
are very much akin to the ability okay
kind of what you get from a Bioshock
right
um where you're you're able to do things
like uh control gravity uh fire ice you
can you can do defensive stuff and this
is all these are all sort of skills that
are upgradable throughout the game right
okay
um to kind of do kind of crazy stuff and
and that that's where the immersive Sim
stuff comes in where you can manipulate
these sort of elements to sort of
enhance the battlefield right on the gun
play side right because you have them
both you have both of the powers and the
Gunplay on the Gunplay side same thing
you're sort of upgrading everything
you're collecting and the cool part
about collecting is that you don't have
to go into every draw whatever you just
put out the tentacle hand and temper the
hand sucks in all the wow yeah it sucks
it Vacuums in like all the upgrade stuff
that you need
so
um so same thing with the guns you
upgrade into guns and the guns get kind
of weird and sort of sci-fi type as the
more stuff you add to it right so
I'm I it's I'm really really enjoying it
because like I saw some reviews that
were like oh like it's wearing too much
of his influences on his sleeve like
it's too much Bioshock it's kind of an
amalgam of all these games but it
doesn't do any of them better and I'm
like you know what's funny yeah like
people say it's too much like Bioshock
name another game like bioshaw that's
the thing like that that's a funny thing
if it was like a rundown thing like
another battle royale like you're
literally saying it's playing too much
like an influence of a game like
Bioshock when people have been screaming
for games like you get another bio shot
yeah let me get another bioshack well
here's the time of heart exactly too
much like biology let me ask you that
because I spoke to somebody and I spoke
to the ray gun and the vibe I'm getting
is like they really want to love it but
they're saying almost like the dialogue
the antagonist is like talking so much
that it's annoying and that it's like
almost for spoken level where it's
immersion breaking so I want to know
like it's not quite for spoken level but
he is annoying he is you know what it is
he's it it's straight up American right
like it this game is set in Russia but
the dude doesn't even have like a
Russian accent when he speaks like he's
straight up Americanized so that takes
you out of the experience in addition to
the fact that he's kind of juvenile
right King and he's like he curses every
five seconds in a way of B.J blaskowitz
and Duke Nukem together yeah okay yes
one character yes but the fact that it's
supposed to be in Russia and he doesn't
have a Russian accent but everybody he
comes across does yeah even like robots
exactly if you've ever played metro
metro the main character Metro arteom
like he has he has that he has that
accent like it yeah and it it draws you
in in a way where this feels like I
don't know if it's a budget thing or
whatever it does feel like a miss that
this that this actor doesn't utilize a
Russian accent to kind of create more
immersion in addition to the fact that
the script wise like scriptwise the
script in some ways is kind of juvenile
and just his conversations and the way
he speaks and then especially how he
interacts with the sentient hand it I I
won't say it's for spoken levels but I'm
gonna have to only only what I've seen
before spoken I haven't played forced
working like that I've just played a
demo so I don't know
that I will be getting that on sale at
some point but
um
yeah I I've seen that and I get it it's
not as to use the word cringy it's not
as cringy to me as forespoken yet and I
just think the rest of the world makes
up for it for me because it is one of
those things where it is it just it it
wholeheartedly buys into the world
that's created okay and everything in
the world fits within that where it's
like some things you find it's like oh
they're not you know they're not really
selling it here right
too I I'll read that later
so
um yeah I I'm really enjoying it
oh we're gonna read that oh you're gonna
read that you're good so I'm really
enjoying the game I think as a first
effort is kind of amazing there are some
things I will let's talk about the
controversies around the game right
racism so that yeah that's the latest
he he races
but this is it right so let's talk about
the initial controversies obviously
um the Ukrainian government is kind of
lobbying against this game because they
feel they don't want Russia to this is a
Russian team and they don't want Russia
to they don't want any products out
there that feels like it's kind of
giving a sort of a elevating the name of
Russia especially in light of what's
happening in the world today right
that that is that is that stance on it
in addition to the fact that there has
been I don't know how true all of this
information is but there is there is
thinking that there is some sort of
controlling stake in mun fish from the
Russian government that could be
directly linked to specifically Russian
oligarchs and that whole thing with sort
of
abuses of power and obviously what's
happening with the Russian Ukraine war
so it it
they've gotten a lot of scrutiny in
terms of
the game and where the the the the dev
Studio sort of gets its funding the
fundings regulation to the Ukrainian
right now yeah so that that's one aspect
of that controversy boycott the game
right completely completely yeah
completely they just don't want anything
that that puts even though this game
doesn't necessarily put Russia in the
you know the context of the game is
saying okay Russia made these the the
supposedly these great you know
scientific advances but you know in
striving to get to this Utopia they
screwed everything up worse than it ever
was right and that that's the idea of
this broken you know dystopian Society
um much in the vein of a Bioshock so the
second controversy with you Cog brought
to mind and knowledge this morning yeah
is apparently so in the safe rooms in
the safe rooms of these of this game and
it's much kind of like Resident Evil
where you go into the same room you can
have a little breather whatever or there
are these TVs that are playing actual
real real shows from 1940s 50s Russia
right and one of the shows that plays in
in there is kind of a Tom and
jerry-esque cartoon with like a I think
a wolf and a rabbit or something like
that
um I guess the wolf constantly trying to
catch the rabbit much like a Tom and
Jerry type situation right and a
specific
episode of this and I don't know if it
happens more than once but uh a twitch
streamer was playing and he he was
looking at this and all of a sudden they
showed
the classic racist representation of of
an African tribes person where literally
like the old school we've seen it in in
cartoons as well uh American cartoons as
well whereas they have this you know a
black tribes person with like big pink
lips and like exaggerated uh sort of
features that were very racist very
racist and they got a lot of flack for
that and you know their response to it
was hey we didn't realize this this is
something that got past us
um we apologize it got passed yeah it
got passed and racism
and and this is the thing right I'm not
gonna sit here
I'm not gonna sit here and be like it's
okay because it's not yeah you really
these are things you really need to
focus on rectifying and not having
happen in your games right
um but it just goes to show
[Music]
when you were outside of the bubble of
the United States the things that get
through and I and it and what other Dev
Studios that are primarily from you know
other countries or whatever they're
primarily in different parts of the
world maybe don't perceive certain
things a certain way as we do
um I say I don't want to I don't want to
project what I think happened here I
don't know opinion piece
right it is my opinion
again it it just it feels like it feels
like there is a a little bit of not not
having the context to read the room and
that in and of itself is a little bit
you know again when
we've seen it here in the states when
people grow up around
black don't grow up where they don't
grow up around people of other races and
colors or whatever they're they have no
context for understanding what's going
to offend us or not
um and I think that part of it is that
and again that's an issue unto itself
that needs to be addressed they did the
right thing they did the right PR thing
to come on but like Hey we're sorry this
got past us we're going to fix it cool
should have never been there
um please they put it in there they sold
they Somebody went and put it to the
television yeah they just pop up in
there exactly oh racial cartoon just
popped up out of the blue so it is one
of those things where yeah uh it
considering all the other Flack the game
is getting it's this just adds to it
again they addressed it quickly I think
they're gonna fix it quickly
um I don't even know my version
[Laughter]
with the racism intact but in speaking
about the product the game yes yes so I
think as a first effort yeah
um and and attempting to emulate a
beloved game and multiple beloved games
right when we talk about the new
Wolfenstein games we talk about Arcane
games it does all of that pretty damn
well and the level of quality in terms
of how the game looks in terms of of the
art the art style and design behind it I
just I really do think they have
something here
um hopefully these devs get to you know
whenever they make their next game to
get to make it removed of any BS
hopefully the situation in Ukraine and
Russia hopefully is resolved and they
can just focus on making games and again
and learning and learning from the
mistakes that they have made and in
addition to be able to improve upon the
game that I think is as a first effort
is really really awesome it really is
uh I didn't play it uh unfortunately
I've been putting a lot of my time into
another game yeah like you're like he
said unfortunately like no it's not
unfortunately it's just unfortunately
since I played this other game so much I
couldn't put time into that game
um because you know it wasn't good it's
gonna be there for you yeah yeah I'll
probably get to it I don't know I got I
got Final Fantasy shout out to Cog after
this because that that's getting beat
like fast so yeah uh you know unless
unless something else comes out that I
gotta review I don't think I'm gonna
review too much uh until like probably
the mid of next month but I mean when it
comes down to it like especially like
the racist stuff it's like
don't sit there and say yo we we it got
passed it's like no yeah
racism
or something it's not the ownership look
you know we we will figure out how this
got into it don't sit there and act like
someone snuck in so I got on a computer
and put some racist thing in the game
and take ownership of it like
you're like you know what let's put some
racist stuff in there I bet you they'll
never even this is my favorite cartoon
it was mad racist beat
man it was mad racist and then again
we've seen I I'm God you remember when
we were in elementary school they used
to they used to put like we you know
when it was raining outside and we they
take us to Auditorium to watch you know
cartoons and stuff during lunch break
and they you know we used to walk the
old school Mischief maker slash you know
Little Rascals and cartoons of that like
black and white cartoons they were put
on for us we're not that old but we used
to watch old cartoons yeah and bro some
of the imagery in those different cars
it's rough it was rough the kid yeah
um okay so let's uh I'm just gonna
attack the racism first
get let's get the racism out the way
oh cause they're gonna patch it oh yeah
it's gonna be gone
they got a racism
I can say so much stuff with that
um but okay so they're gonna go fix it
and it's a desensitivity to something
that you didn't grow up around
um because if you had somebody that you
grew up around and you were watching
this cartoon
you would say no I can't I can't pass
that I can't do it right so you can't
feel for something that's not in your
circumference that's just it and I will
say it's ignorant to that part and then
once it's out there they say wow we
didn't know that we were insensitive to
this so let's pull this back and let's
take this back I'm not saying that in
Russia I've seen a lot of black people
there anyway so just the same way when I
played the game I really was looking for
black people I didn't see it
until I got to the television
yeah yeah in the whole place you could
see black people in Russia is on
television
so the only depiction that I see the
black people was a racist cartoon I'm
like oh oh man oh buddy
in for it right okay another thought
process that I'm thinking the fact that
you know Russia's versus Ukraine and I
try to stay away from the political uh
nonsense officials
um that's probably the main reason why
the character doesn't sound Russian
right because okay he's going against
Russian things in a fake Russian World
so let's let's break immersion and make
them sound American so we're not
constantly reminded that this uh Russian
hero right so just you know make his
voice American that's just my thought of
it yeah
um when it comes to that I think it was
a thought process in doing it instead of
elevating a Russian hero we can Elevate
like an American hero American sounding
hero that's probably born in Russia but
you separate that
um
yeah so if you want to boycott the game
for that then you know do so if you want
to boycott the game for the Russian uh
racism uh aspect of it do so that's that
got past the screen racism yo but see I
didn't know none of this stuff was
thing until I saw the cartoon myself
yeah I had to watch it yeah yeah no I
yeah but I didn't run out and say
because I really I didn't run out and
say oh my God they got racism
they're wild crazy now
as far as Bioshock they nailed it
the world looks so beautiful it looks so
alive it's so creative in this thought
of what it could be like uh how all the
robots is helping it feels like
Have You Ever Seen The Stepford Wives it
feels like that type of world right
where all the automations and stuff and
and there's another movie that's going
to come out I think it's like go to the
moon or something like that where
they're living in a separate World a
different world-changing events happen
um they have cars they don't drive but
robots come and take the cars to where
they gotta go it's it's just little
things and the world is just so
beautifully done and I've played it on
my series X and my Series S I've I
haven't seen any you know real
differences to be honest with you maybe
I wasn't really looking for it I I try
to do it all the time just to see you
know run downstairs and play and I go
upstairs and play yeah um
it felt very polished and full the first
run on a series on on this I can see
this having legs yeah like it's just
it's we need another Bioshock we haven't
got another Bioshock and in this stead
we have like uh Duke Nukem uh wolf and
stain uh Bioshock amalgamation of a game
I like walking around doing this on the
screen like yeah so we're doing the the
X-ray stuff yeah yeah you're scanning
things with the glove in your hand I
gotta get in this game and to be honest
it's not it's not as smart as Bioshock
like Bioshock Bioshock is a masterpiece
for a reason
um but it emulates it very well and
again as a first effort it's it's very
good I like it when you run up on granny
yeah you're gonna love Granny for her
candle I love the candle of the
characters because they pretty much say
the stuff like how the real world would
be I love is a little uh secret about
somebody inside the total
when you make when you make the
Wolfenstein comparisons right it is that
feeling of it's a lived-in world right
it's very much lived in it when I say
they go for it 100 there's nothing about
that world that feels like they didn't
go in on you know this is this we're all
in on what this world is and how it
operates and every little aspect of it
is is true to it like in a way that
doesn't feel like they cut Corners
anywhere really yeah it's a very well
made game so when they first showed this
game and I was excited for the game I'm
still excited playing the game so a lot
of times you get a game and you see this
the the virtual slice or I mean the
vertical slice oh yeah see the gameplay
and then you get the game and it just
didn't live up to those initial
expectations of the game right but what
I can say is from every trailer that
I've seen from any uh videos that I saw
of it to act actually playing the game
it lives up to everything that I thought
it would be it's unfortunate that it
does have uh the racism uh it's
unfortunate that you know Ukraine and
Russia is at War right now it's
unfortunate that this gem has a lot of
these controversies surrounding it
if if they didn't have these
controversies I think this game will be
uh very up there you know uh what a 80
90 Metacritic like 85 90 Metacritic I
would think it would be but then the
controversy will probably drag it down
to some point yeah yeah is it their
first game
I'm sorry
I was gonna say if you guys noticed that
like you know there's a lot of first
games going on that's actually really
prominent games a really solid first
experiences I feel like we in the next
like five ten years we're going to get a
lot of good experiences because like
these these studios are coming out with
really solid first experiences yeah yeah
I'm sorry real quick so yeah this game
has some like some pause moments too
that they had these these these dual
rope I know I I saw a super chat this
dual robots that are just like
uh I don't want to like like they're
they're sexual upgrade boxes
yeah and they they got you know like
much like the main protagonist the the
the the the language is colorful right
and then there's also if I haven't
gotten to this point myself at the door
maybe I've missed it there is a it's a
basement scene where there is like these
turbines going and one like a turbine
straight up looks like a like a just
like a just like a it looks like a
phallus and it looks like a masturbating
phallus
wow there's got a lot going for it
there's some pause the pause movements
in this game
shout out to to Xbox too because they
they you know I will say that game pass
Day One games sometimes is a hit and
miss depending on what type of gamer you
are but you know this game and you know
uh another game in the future I I think
I think they're they're they're finding
their good whole strategy when it comes
to getting these gains because you know
sure these games not be tied to
exclusive is but the fact that you could
pop in there if you have an Xbox game
pass subscription or a PC to some of
these games it just downloads them and
try them out like especially you know uh
atomic heart that's their first game
their second game might not be in Game
Pass but you know what's going to be in
that second game your experience for low
entry going into your first game makes
you more probable buying their second
game yep sure yeah no it's a big get for
Game Pass obviously we wait wait so are
you saying that people have Game Pass
buying more games
okay so I'm saying in certain situations
they buy more games
no it's a big third party get for them
obviously you know I spoke to to Maddie
about it I mean he was he was very
strong about dialogue which is
interesting you know but it is
conflicted I'm seeing people on the
other side of the fence as far as like
the the the actual people love the world
building people love um again that
Bioshock type Vibe kind of thing gotta
be honest
think I'm good right now with the
situation of the um cartoon so you know
but again this is not car grandstanding
you know and saying yo if you buy it and
you play it you enjoy it you're evil and
you support racism no I'm I'm good
you're gonna say like I just that takes
me back to a certain era of um cartoons
that I grew up with that I didn't really
relate to that part stuff so hopefully
they correct it looks like they try to
jump out in front of it
um but about all by no means am I
judging anyone who's having a good time
in the game and all that but let me ask
it let me ask a question uh have you
guys uh you know be in the demographic
side effects like yeah because you see a
lot of people doing stuff like this and
trying to you know make it right yeah
like to me I don't think there's any way
to make that right like what like what
could they do yeah it's personal choice
because I know where you're going
there's a part that's like yo they jump
in front of it they correct the mistake
right so don't
things are lost culturally right and I
get that right but then there's also the
standpoint where some people feel like
yo like once you got that in there that
already identifies yourself on how you
truly feel and who you know listen I
probably just got a bunch of cognitos
yeah and I'm gonna keep the same energy
that I've said with Hogwarts and
everything else like I don't judge
anyone that's like yo it's not that big
a deal and I'm good and I'm having no
power to you I don't get away from you
I'm just saying for me I'm not rocking
with it you know what I'm saying but
it's all good it's whatever it is let me
read the Super Chat and because it gives
a little contest Lawrence Davenport five
dollar Super Chat as a black man who
lived in Russia I would put it more to
ignorance than bigotry yeah and again
I'm not calling them out well you know
I'm saying like yo what that yo
everybody gotta get in through the line
and we gotta stop you know I'm not is
it's a member I always said this is
always personal it's a personal choice
right it's a personal decision it
couldn't be more personal yeah to be
honest with you that's all it is and
everyone has the right to feel like
everyone has the right long as we all
respectful to each other with where we
at with it I think we're fine so that's
just where I'm at
cool anybody else anybody else uh yeah
we got these super chats
yeah if you like BioShock
yeah it's like you're probably gonna
like this yeah it definitely it
definitely is it's not as good as
Bioshock but it again it's it's it's
very knowledge though I definitely
polished and for the first joint yeah I
was afraid that it wouldn't be polished
and
it was the first time I went swimming in
the polymer yeah I was like oh snap this
is a joke it looks like a barrier at
first yeah and then it's inviting and
then the character tells you oh I've
been swimming through polymer before
I've never been hurt right you don't
have any fear after that you're like oh
okay okay and by all accounts it looks
really nice it looks really nice on the
uh on the Xbox
oh I mean it is beautiful because you
have you have parts of it that are very
kind of industrial right and then once
when you go into like uh like government
buildings and you have like these lavish
sort of like crazy
um elaborate offices like decals and
stuff like that when in the beginning
right when you go up to the the head
scientist sort of office and you go up
in this elevator this glass elevator
kind of reminds me of when you're
dropping down in Rapture but you're
going out and you you're immediately met
by these two female like like robots and
you go in and the dude has like air
airplanes literally
airplanes are like kind of like it's
almost like they crashed into his office
so they're kind of like jutting in
through the window but it's part of like
the decoration it's really it's really
ostentatious giant 747 exactly that
they're real giant life-sized exact 47s
inside of his his name wow house where
he lives and the big robots block you
from going in but yeah the the giant
planes are there right now when you go
downstairs and you're getting your
little flying car and they take you out
takes you around the building yes see
through the glass and you can see the
giant planes inside the glass
is a visual Masterpiece yeah it's
beautiful yeah well like when you're on
the boat in the water and there's so
many different things going on that
stuff can't it it I'm waiting for the
engine to break right while I'm playing
the game because it's people walking
around and there's stuff floating in the
air and it is it's it's populated it's
not um a desolate it's very popular with
so many things going on in so many
different dialogues that's happening
while you walk into the places that you
got to walk through I'm waiting for the
engine to break at some point in time
and I didn't have that experience that
the World building is something else
like it really is like you walk around
you the world feels lived in that's what
I love about those games so yeah on the
PC obviously I'm always caveat things
with the PC now
it runs beautifully but there's no RTX
across the board yeah I don't know it's
funny because this was supposed to be
one of those RTX showpieces yeah um when
they first announced it and there's no
RTX anywhere to be seen I don't know you
know what the situation is with that but
I know that was a a talking point early
on where it's like oh the RTX isn't
going to make it for long oh well yeah
yeah exactly yeah well no it's across
the board like there is no RTX on the
Xbox version
but I was just saying so you haven't
well yeah the master race as well you
know having the same experience we are
that's that's what you want to know
for considerably more money yes
and some people pay 70 dollars
that is true too I can't I believe shout
out to Game Pass PC
messy we all good yeah let me get these
super chats we got a couple let me play
with the four Horsemen's joysticks
together two dollars Super Chat past the
sticks we can play couch Co-op or the
bed wow
wow wow because we're ridiculous there's
nothing else that could be said all
right so real quick question while he
reads those
um
is everyone seemed pretty good to do the
community and stuff next week next
Saturday
what I I was gonna ask the I was gonna
have us all pick a game and let them
pick a quick recipe
then we got Robert Kelly two dollar
Super Chat so this P3 have fun it has a
have a fun time with the robot twins
that said the robot twins something else
they do they look like Wonder Woman
was all metal yeah yeah
then we got I read this one from
Lawrence Davenport then we have four as
a legend remember for two years five
dollars which had solved that upgrade
box to something else like an atomic
heart but honestly it's a really good
game and joyful is yes the upgrade box
just look around look out for the
upgrade box whoa now that's sound wow
that's foul wow
thank you
out of here
so um let's start first with our psvr
you know I'm saying there is uh the VR2
has dropped and uh I guess let's just
start with kig first and then we gotta
lead it I guess you're expecting you
want to start song with your impressions
yeah what's gonna happen
um at this point we we spent like 200
plus bucks on that game we streaming
that I haven't even installed it yet bro
what's going with you because you
definitely I got a chance at all too
okay oh experience PS4 I must shift the
day I was actually flying out the
Houston so I did not get a chance to get
the touch on my psvr too so let's start
with your impressions first okay yeah so
I got mine on Tuesday
um and yeah first thing I noticed was
that the box is Matt small like I
thought it was going to be this huge
freaking box I I don't remember King it
was the original did it come in like
this big ass box yeah so this is like
packaging wise is super you know
PlayStation that they they're not going
to route of Xbox with the packaging it's
very thin packaging so yeah so was it
was it a a premium experience when he
was opening yeah no not at all no 100 uh
purchase no that that I will say that
it's a nice looking box whatever it's
it's smaller than I expected it but it's
not the premium rapping welcome to the
PlayStation it wasn't that like it
wasn't like oh here you go it's like a
street vendor Burger you did I won't say
that either
wrap it up it wasn't it wasn't like when
I opened up my series actions like oh
and there wasn't that because yeah some
people capping talking about the
PlayStation you know ship out was it was
it did it have Atari Jaguar energy no
not that bad
well the inside the the inside holder
for the thing is a milk carton it is it
definitely is
energy
so but once I once I got the
so the first when I got the headset out
and and set everything up the setup is
very easy
um one thing I I kind of didn't realize
is that it's the connection that it has
to the system it's a hard line
connection it's not like a USB you plug
in and out the connection that's to the
to the headset is is is directly
connected to the headset it's not a USB
that pops in and out just the USB on the
console okay right yeah so it's not
basically the physical stays it stays
because
right exactly so it's it is Tethered to
to the PlayStation
yeah no it doesn't that's what I'm
saying it clicks into the PlayStation
regular USB connection but on the on the
headset side it is built into it oh
there is no disconnecting it on the
headset SSI so like that cord or your
ear is basically staying there there's
no power it's staying there exactly it's
staying there
um the controllers seem very they seem
very very cool I like the design they're
comfortable
um same thing once I once I got the
machine up and running like it is that
same thing when you see your hands in in
VR and it does that same thing with the
thumbs up and the Hand starts sticking
out the fingers start sticking out
whatever so it's same type of deal
um like I said setting it up was very
easy the coolest thing about this
headset is that it has the eye tracking
right and the eye tracking stuff is cool
like mostly so far I've only seen it and
sort of like navigating menus like you
can look up look down whatever
um there is eye tracking like res
infinite a game that's very old but uh I
don't it doesn't seem to work super well
for me in Residence just rather use the
controllers
so yeah immediately upon throwing the
headset on so the way it's it's set up
now it has the dial in the back right so
the dial basically you pull you pull
like the front out and the you and you
adjust it to your to your head size
right
you also are able to pull out the front
part of the screen you press a button on
the right side on the top of the of the
sort of where the the lens is and you
can slide that part in and out and
adjust it individually from the back
strap right so usually what you would do
is you you pull out that front part you
adjust it to your face right and then
you then and then you adjust the back
part and then you tighten the knob in
the back to get the get the best fit
possible right now in terms of the setup
once you do that uh it has the eye
tracking setup but it also has the setup
where obviously BR has a very it has a
very small sweet spot and this is the
same for most VR right and this is kind
of no different The Sweet Spot is very
particular so what it does in this in
this headset it has something for you to
dial it in so you could basically what
happens is it shows you how you have the
headset situated on your head if it's if
it's a little crooked or whatever yeah
so you can adjust it to straighten it
out you can straighten it out and it and
it shows you and it shows you on the
screen hey straighten it out a little
bit like this yes and what happens is it
has the dial to sort of indicate the
ideal distance for your ipv which is the
ipd exactly quick question before you go
on because I gotta ask for glasses gay
like how we feeling because some
headsets you know I know the pro kind of
has a little space between like how are
you feel were you playing with glasses
were you not I have my contacts on I
tried with the glasses but my you know
the glasses that I wore once on the show
are never again yeah they're Big Frame
so yeah
so I found it to be I found it to be
tight I tried it one time I put them on
now the ability to get the headset on is
there and there's no extra piece just
like oh the glasses piece yeah so I can
use it with the headset right the
headset because of how it adjusts front
and back all you have to do is kind of
you pull the front out a little bit more
you pull the back out a little bit more
get your glasses on or whatever and you
don't need any extra pieces
um but I did find that the the fit was
too tight for me okay it kind of
squeezed on my head I gave a little bit
of headache so I just I stay with my
contacts okay so in in the ipd setup all
you have is a knob a little like a knob
up here on the left hand side upper
left-hand side that allows you to sort
of dial it in so that it's perfect so
your eyes are fitting are are perfectly
sort of situated and distance wise and
in terms of trying to get the the best
lock on onto the sweet spot right and
and the thing is that there's feedback
telling you hey you got it right boom
nice good you got it right and every
time you take on the do you put all you
take it off and put it back on it's
possible you have to redo it because it
won't be perfect every single time right
but
I'm gonna but it it was super easy and
sometimes it isn't super easy right and
the fact that you know camera wise
everything is internal it's nice
it isn't it it it's very very easy to
set up which I was happy about it's just
huge yeah yeah so then going into
initially you go into and you start you
see your regular PlayStation sort of
dashboard and sort of pancake mode or
whatever but in 3D mode yeah
um oh so quick quick addition to that
right so you have the cinema mode that
you can do in addition to the VR stuff
right the cinema mode allows you to
watch to play you know pancake
PlayStation games okay okay with a
simulated right with a simulated big
screen right and you could you could
increase so decrease the size of the
screen as you see fit another cool thing
is if you don't have uh a 120 hertz HDR
TV the headset is 120hz HDR so you can
technically like if you don't have a TV
that you can get that performance out of
let's say God of War Ragnarok you can
play it on the headset and you will get
that performance out of it you'll get
that 120hz
you can bypass the the the the
shortcomings of your TV you know this is
it this is the Infuse you that's
hilarious
so upon jumping into games right after
all the setup whatever the first thing I
played the first thing that downloaded
because uh call of the mountain didn't
download as quickly I got the resume wow
we call it a wow yeah call it a while
we're still downloading so the first
thing I played in VR was the Resident
Evil 8 demo right I said let me see how
the horror does let's go
I'm happy to report that the Hara is oh
my god oh yeah it's really VR bro it is
real and listen I'm gonna tell you this
I'm not good for VR for more than an
hour right the Comfort level of the
headset allows me to get that hour hour
15. other headsets I the the headache
sets in or whatever I just can't so for
me it's an hour hour 15 tops so I'm glad
I'm able to do that right
um but I again for me I just start
getting it just starts feeling tight and
whatever
um but the headset is super comfortable
so I go it is comfortable as well right
especially for those who had the
original headset and was pretty much the
most comfortable headset on the market
yeah
no the controllers they last pretty long
they do they they like pretty much
[Laughter]
demo right so the demo starts you out
um in the training mode and you're kind
of like in this basement dungeon and
immediately you're like oh wow this
feels grimy and dirty
and it's like and it teaches you all the
stuff if you've been playing VR you kind
of know like the reloading hot you know
now did you do did you do movement mode
or did you deploy two they had the point
two mode
with res evil I did The Click two mode
okay so he actually something that I
looked over so uh this this headset
allows you to set up for three different
sort of types of Play Sitting mode
standing mode or full room mode right
um so for me the space I could do
standing mode but I tend to move around
a little bit I don't want to
accidentally bump into something oh
what's up we got our pass through so
when you say yes
okay there's a button there's a button
underneath
that is the pass-through button oh
that's right any moment boom ladies you
want to talk you want to see exactly
what's going on fire okay exactly oh
another thing is no it's black and white
it's black and white no color plastic it
is black and white so another thing is
they give you shut up they give you
stereo stereo headphones
yes it has color fast
I'm not gonna hold the team this
situation
consumer prices
exactly but but
go inside your room and put your headset
on without turning on the place
oh you can't do that right so now that
you can't see VR we're having that that
PlayStation 5 yeah you own a 1200 scale
too but the fact that I guess for 300
more you could have got color past
this guy this guy yeah we're gonna be an
updated patch
yourself
oh my God so yeah so yeah that part of
the setup was very cool because again it
allows you to those different options
um again it's very simple to set up and
it no no issues with that whatsoever so
going back to Resident Evil right so you
go into kind of they start you out with
the navigation stuff and I I was doing
the snap navigation and it was just just
turning the camera around
um doing that and I was sitting I was
sitting so then you get to the point
where it's just uh now you're doing like
okay how do you grab stuff off of your
inventory and stuff like that so there's
this thing where you you open up your
jacket with one hand and you grab your
flashlight right and you're able to use
the flashlight individually and stuff
like that
um then we get into the weapons training
right weapons training if you played any
sort of weapon based game in VR kind of
the same thing where it's like okay
um grab your grab the weapon one hand
you know use the other hand to sort of
reload magazines and stuff like that
kind of very intuitive if you've done it
already if you have it you're like oh
wait I have this level of control and
details like yeah just grab the magazine
click the magazine in pull pull back the
the what you would call it the hammer
and you know that you can do it they
show you how to shoot with your with a
shotgun with a pistol machine gun
um you have your knife that you could
that you can swipe you can slice with
and you can Chuck as well you could
chuck a few things as well so super
super uh sort of
intuitive and everything's super
interactable okay
um barely interact with everything so
then we go into the demo proper right so
is this a time demo or is that just a
demo you can keep going back and play
um I don't think it's times no I don't
think it's time you can go back and play
it yeah absolutely go back and play it
it doesn't start you at the beginning of
the game though it starts you after if
you play uh residential Village uh after
Ethan crashed there's a crash and then
Ethan gets to the Village so it starts
you there and if you guys remember
no I didn't play it you didn't play
Village okay there's a part where Ethan
he well he gets to the Village right
actually he didn't plug that oh wow oh
you didn't shocked okay I think
something came out I've been meaning to
go back to it but then when they
announced the third party uh the third
view thing I was on my way for that and
then I came out and then something else
came out and I'm like okay I guess it's
getting pushed back forward so so
there's a part right in the beginning
kind of there's a beginning part and
then the demo starts at this other part
where uh there's a crash Ethan is kind
of by himself he's trying to figure out
where he is and it's the middle of the
night and he's traversing through this
like little wooded area Forest area in
the snow
right so that part imagine that part in
VR okay where all you're hearing all
these wow crazy sounds coming out of the
forest it's real Blair Witch craziness
and you're and and literally you can you
can go up this little hill part you can
go up this it's not it's not super sort
of uh directed you you have some
leverage to the side some lateral
movement so it's just it's kind of
terrifying when you it's all
encompassing I'm like oh they did it
sound it's crazy the sound is okay so
back to the sound so what they give you
is they in the Box they give you these
two little earbuds and the earbuds
attach directly to the headset right
okay okay
attached to the headset from like
underneath right there under the under
rim or whatever and then there are two
little slots on the sides where you
could literally like Park the earbuds
when you aren't using them so you tuck
them into like this little thing and
they stay it's Kings Big King they got
earbuds you like that that's big for you
yeah yo that's definitely dope like I
heard also it has the um the 3D audio
with it okay right so the 3D I at first
I had heard that you could use your 3D
headsets the pulse headsets but I don't
really see the I have the pulse headsets
I don't really see how that is on top
like on top of the joints
yeah I thought I saw somebody with a
headset I don't know if it was that
particular one but I could have swore I
saw someone with a headset over it but I
could be wrong it feels like it would be
super bulky yeah I got one yeah I'm sure
it does I don't know it feels like aces
in the chat it's a game on daily VR
expert
yeah let us know if you got that how did
that box taste pause
yeah tell us if you got the um the 3D
audio headset or use an external headset
I'm very curious about that as well
continue so
so yeah um it was terrifying I woke up
my wife
so I I'm probably gonna end up getting
the full game nice nice
um so let's get into I played a little
bit of I hadn't played Moss originally
so I got lost into that I want to play
book two as well I got old school two
two older games that I know are great in
in VR which is res infinite oh yeah and
um
I don't know what you're talking about
oh this guy here
continue we'll get to it but
um obviously I played the uh the the
PlayStation launch title right the
showpiece again that Horizon called this
goal
of the mountain let's go when you throw
it on you understand the power behind
the the headset right the game is
beautiful the game is beautiful the
headset the headset avails itself very
well it is a great headset thanks for
greatness is talking to you it is
telling you see the devil's car you go
in and you are you're a shadow you play
okay so you don't play no no oh no no no
he plays a troll
next song
so you play you play as a shadow who has
been uh sort of they they they they
kidnapped no if you play the game you
know where the shadow card is
so anyway but this dude he you've seen
him before and and no no no
so this is a random dude
all right insert player a
it is a VR experience you are the player
this is of no consequence if something
happened to this dude it doesn't affect
the real main story this is
something happened you know we're good
this could be this could this could be
the crossover that I did Horizon threes
I could see yourself
so it starts out that uh you've been
taking prisoner you've been taken
prisoner by um
yeah she just shows up for the product
endorsement and you're in like you're in
this you're sure but it's like do you
want to see more of this individual by
your other day
if you like this game why don't you try
the real one
well they for free now it's for free
yeah free hell yeah cause it ain't
performed let's get back on focus of the
left of distraction Focus now strictly
I'm talking about this traffic
so they have you prison are you tied up
in a kayak and you're in the river and
[Laughter]
the first thing you notice is the scale
of the world immediately you see these
these these metal dinosaurs or whatever
screaming underneath you rocking the
boat you see the tall neck and you're
looking around you and it's so and
that's the thing it's all if you're if
you're playing standing right if you're
playing standing you're spinning around
looking at everything and the scale of
the world is impressive gorgeous and the
resolution I just have one question
how's the compound okay so the combat
well I'll get to in a second but let me
finish talking about this game the main
Crux of the game I'll talk about that
later yes
so but you got to talk about the ability
of the headset to give you the visuals
right
so the visuals like anything like any of
his own rails
yeah that part is not you're just that's
like that's like the cutscene okay oh
so
what happened you get attacked by I
forgot what was it the stormbird I think
it was or whatever flips over your um
the kayak and now it's on you to Escape
right and you're you're climbing or
whatever if you're done climbing in in
VR you know what that is right it's one
hand above the other like this climbing
it if you played the climb on meta Quest
um so then you escape
um as you're escaping now now the point
is to climb up this mountain and escape
from the the two captors right or trying
to because you need to prove good
question bad question if you fall does
this show you legitly falling I didn't I
didn't I didn't do it I didn't do it I'm
assuming I let go and I dropped and then
I grabbed on again okay but I didn't I
didn't I didn't do this cool that's cool
but I will I will try it I will try
people motion sickness that's fine so
you can commit uh you commitment
so you're climbing up uh like a vast
sort of cliff and you're looking around
you and again the scale of the world is
super impressive
um and you're trying because as you're a
shadow card there that's been wrongly
accused of something he's trying to sort
of clear his name okay
um
so when you get to the top of the cliff
you're always sort of explaining that
game
Jesus get messy sometimes you're just
talking to talk now yeah you know what
they hear they hear the sabotage
once I see addict make that face it's
over this time it's over what's that
needed with that face I knew it was over
here so
the combat the combat again here we go
is much like any other VR game like it's
when you oh I'm done right that's all
that's all I need to do here that's how
to buy but again the Fidelity is what
makes it different yeah
um basically you have your bow you have
your arrow you're reaching back to grab
your arrow you're setting it up
um and you're taking shots what I
realized a little bit what I realized a
little bit from the shooting is that it
it helps you a little bit too much
there's other games that I played in VR
where you're aiming so even the
shootings of rails Jesus Christ oh my
God Jesus Christ
there's games that that focus on that
that have done it and again it's fine
it's fine you get a little bit of help
you get like a little bit of a ping ping
oh okay you have it lined up right here
that's what's up yeah
um
and that's essentially all that I've
played of it I haven't had a lot of
again when it comes to the scale the
scope of it it's there when you see the
the ability of the headset it's there
my issue and it's the same issue I had
before we talked about it is this is a
great headset that that is for this wall
garden and that's it it's do you hope
and do you pray that PlayStation invests
in it in the way that you want to get
the most out of the headset right and
that's where my worry lies because Tech
wise you're not gonna get a better
headset for this price you're not
because the next step up is a Vive with
mad cameras around you yeah and a 1500
PC in addition to the thousand dollar
Vibe or whatever it is that's the next
step up that's how good this is for what
it is right nice
um 1500 product versus a 1500 product
I don't know what those numbers
the next joint came up he was like
here's the next one so that is my only
worry and then the the
the thing about it is that after
watching the state of play and the five
games that they talked about yeah man I
was like oh damn like it was it was like
it was like more Shooters another one
that like everything is a variation of a
shooter right
and that's a little worrying to me
because none of the stuff that I saw at
the state of play seemed exciting to me
maybe one thing with the the multiple
sort of like the people that you were
the little dog was sorry
yeah exactly beyond that everything else
felt like a variation of a shooter and
that's kind of if you played VR before
it's a little tired so it is that thing
of like just got it um
and that's my worry that's my worry with
PlayStation it's like does it have Vita
vibes
oh my God the quality yeah the quality
without this without the support yeah
remember Vita yeah I remember a lot of
games did you what else did you pay yeah
I call it you just picked up you just
call it a mountain and the devil Raz
um the uh resident the Moss the thumper
um again but I heard gt7 is nice I heard
people no man's Sky
yes no man's Sky amazing
no man's Sky it's one of those things
like am I really gonna sit and play No
Man's sky like that I know it's amazing
but it is one of those things when I
think about how much time at a time I
can be in VR yeah I think I'm I'm mostly
looking for the small experiences you
know what I mean but but I heard no
man's sky is transformative in video
that's what I'm hearing that's what I
mean I'm gonna find myself I'll go quick
and then we'll jump into these two but
wait
yeah smoke but uh no look I'm very upset
because it's like shout out to my LS7 I
had to go fly out I had to see them and
I'm like damn why could this ship one
day before so I can have time I'm
literally packing and how to fly in the
morning so I didn't get a chance to play
so I'm hoping if not tonight tomorrow
this week definitely I'm um unboxing get
into that but uh yeah I'm curious
obviously I have the the call the
mountain
um obviously demio I want to see what
that's looking like over there and then
um there's a couple games Zenith I
really think you should give a shot
because Zenith is it bro it's almost
how Fantasy Star or line I want it to be
and it's it has Jr I would love attic to
try this kid because it has jrpg
sensibilities you could tell the like
this is a world that is the only
beautiful yes
[Laughter]
tell me tell me where you did there I've
played it all the questions to the
questions on the quest what on the quest
Pro I had to press question okay so you
are hot you you a high fidelity dude
yeah yeah you are you an apex predator
can you remind us how much that headset
costs well the question is available now
for four hundred dollars and the quest
pro has been reduced in price for about
1300.
it's the same price as the one you got
but we're not here for talking about it
but I will say the fact that like you
can you can rock with it without it it's
like going to buy a car but you need the
engine stop playing uh all I would say
is look my psvr two on this plea like
gives Edith a shot yard this game is
phenomenal I think it will be one of the
few games from uh but I can go get that
at the quest too right now yeah you can
get that as a question but for psvr two
orders who do not have requests and it
has
in other places I was just talking about
so you purchased this console to play
games that you could play
what what what exclusive so you got oh
now we do it exclusive
just to clarify where's this energy
coming when it comes to Game Pass that's
what I'm saying like you know what
exclusives do you play on Game Pass that
you can't get anywhere else yeah if
they're dropping game passes exclusive
anyway shout out to ASA he's what he's
doing he's got five okay yeah contract
look you know I know big chamber is
eventually coming
um yeah
right now
too yeah I got it right now in the quest
I need to know what's gonna get me over
to that PS5 The Horizon
that's the Colorado West how many
mountains you gotta climb see from what
I heard about it right uh what you heard
there's a lot of news here I mean you're
talking with Chase
let's get clearly he don't want me to
talk about so he wants to talk now
somebody would have to say he didn't
even play it so you just that's true
that is true that is true yeah so you've
given us your experiences off of that
apex predator that you guys
apex predator do when you brought the
little boxes
your Oculus search little man
people should pick up now that they're
new owners and like I said I wanted to
shout out no Ben Sky They just added
that mode I wanted to shout out what was
the other one um Gran Turismo which I
want to try I just wanna pay 70 I didn't
pick up Grant people before
I
upgraded my PlayStation to the top 10 to
see if I could get it for a discount or
for free and it's like that
I was like damn but I got Horizon
um the the new one but not uh I got the
video anyway long story short check it
out we'll see I'll give my Impressions
probably next week after uh play this
week but I would love to hear your
impressions
it doesn't seem like that you know why I
love his impression because he got
something that's a real direct
competitor you know to this situation
that just came out that got a bunch of
same experiences that everybody could do
right now I'm just saying it's clearly
kick what's the time so kick Chevy
transition to your version yeah let's
talk about what Lord's gaming
shout out to Tina
well you can get the finest gaming news
first uh so clearly he wants to talk
about uh potential widespread controller
issues some control potential control
issues with the VR2 launch so shout out
to G Lord Jing from Lords gaming.net so
apparently this was on the psvr
subreddit where people are saying that
the um they saw prop some people are
having problems with the sense
controllers and it says that um right
out of the box report a problem is that
one of the two controllers will not work
during game play the controls work fine
in the menu yet as soon as a game starts
One controller will not respond to
inputs and the king is out of pocket
um yeah so pretty much the people have
been going to the Reddit and support
threads to try to get information I
think there is a short term fix
um this kicks on this is pocket chaotic
button mashing just keep bashing the
buttons on the effective controller into
the wake up and then um some people said
power down to PS5 and while off press
and hold the power button to the second
beep
connected
people says with USB and press the
PlayStation uh button then clear the
cache and they talk about some other uh
fixes to to get it to get it going you
said you got to catch the cat you got to
clear the cash he said
it's a wild Street cat
I'm out of control so some people have
shut down their PS5 they chose to
rebuild the database once it goes to the
restart thing and then um with sense
controls are off they reset both of them
and then they started VR again and now
everything works so kid clearly wanted
to talk about this potential issue that
is on the uh Reddit uh Playstation VR
Reddit okay so this is the reason why I
ain't hear about it because when they go
to complain they don't go to Twitter
yeah y'all go to Reddit so I know where
y'all at now
so all right the fact that I could go
into my PlayStation right now and I can
get a PlayStation VR with new issues
oh I could go to Best Buy right now pick
up with no issues
they're available in stores right now
for the for the for the small group of
y'all who did purchase I know this ain't
funny though I mean if you get something
like hey and and you you in the menu
everything is dope and you ready and
then you playing what's that game Hot
Shots because they play a bunch of old
games
right and then you go to pull out your
gun and your right gunning
Twitter
you messy
who the hell found to work around with
hold left trigger and squeezed the right
trigger and then pull out the USB but
make sure you hold the PlayStation
button on the Dual set listen can you
release the cash
release the kiss no who the hell yo that
was a desperate news
yo he saw his six hundred dollars
that was a desperate dude yeah I know I
know it has happened that you have
purchased something and it comes in
broke it
oh
Where is the
is the dudes for this
I know you dudes now you're not on
Twitter I haven't saw no one on Twitter
talk about oh my controllers are not
syncing properly but all already that's
where you hide so I'm going there I just
wanted to know oh not Cobb [__] Cog the
jury's still out
risk okay so I obviously solved you
haven't run into this widespread no I
mean I I tend to have good luck with my
with Hardware good I have not had this
issue thank goodness good good
it's just uh I just want to know where's
the same energy for this widespread
obviously
it's widespread everybody been talking
about it all over Reddit
and it's just the right controller that
don't want to listen
wait wait why is attic not talking what
happened
he didn't finish two games
so the last joke which was the voters
that we wanted to talk about oh I was
muted this whole time
yes
because the VR look
I just I need to see more games like
demio stuff stuff that is only on that
yeah to get me on that platform
um if you like VR I I'm glad you got
something like this is just not for me
it's kind of more like the Call of Duty
thing uh you know happy for you man I
I'm more looking forward to like the
Spidermans of the year uh but I'm sure
they'll make some good experience the
one thing I will say is when it comes to
like uh you know the quest uh the uh the
steam I kind of a little bit more uh you
know experience with steam doing stuff
because of like the Val like he's gonna
take games to drive people without those
platforms and I will say out of everyone
a console manufacturer making the VR is
better for the VR than anyone else
because they understand the importance
of games
that's what you hope right but my thing
is like it's just that to me they have
to start thinking about their VR headset
like they're starting to think about you
know PC games and putting it like you
have to open up the wall Garden like
because when you and you think about it
even though again it's it's
it's it's the norm now on PC but what
you could do on PC with a headset and
you know the freedom there
that's kind of where the exciting stuff
is happening
so unless PlayStation is really going to
dedicate themselves to make like
exclusive VR experiences for this
headset that innovate and move and try
to move the the sort of the medium
forward yeah that it's gonna it's gonna
stag me it's gonna continue to be
stagnated because again they're not it's
it's a great headset that is hindered by
the fact that it's only a PlayStation
headset right but I mean look it's you
know the the potential if they leverage
their first party IP yes like could you
imagine something last of us you know
could you imagine something goes Toshiba
that's the hope I have right
the biggest thing and I think the
biggest issue they had with the Vita is
just try to make their games
work audible yes yes like you need to
have these developers or hire other
developers to make games that make sense
as a VR experience yes don't just make a
climbing simulator with hey Lord don't
just make you know stuff like The
Walking Dead
my climbing simulator
you know this is something like
one one review did call it that that's
it look at demio The Walking Dead you
know I think they need to do more stuff
with social games like like scramble
poker games
yeah yeah that's the thing like you know
if you don't okay let's say all right
you know you get the people there by
using these experiences like doing the
card games Yu-Gi-Oh magic yo Kaijudo uh
uh Pokemon there's so many opportunities
you get them in you you get them in the
facility you get them in the building
then you start having your first party
make you know a little bit more amp up
the the outage on it like contact
whoever owns uh Monopoly these days like
yo can I make a Last of Us border uh uh
a Last of Us Monopoly game can I do that
and put it on the platform nice kid
laughing
everyone is so funny
yo cause it's like build it and they
will come
ain't nobody's showing up but this is
the thing this is this is what I hope
they understand it's like yo the
PlayStation name yes make the most of it
and and exactly this is what they gonna
do y'all gotta stop I hear all his hopes
and dreams
don't get me wrong they build a platform
these are lazy dudes
they build a platforms and they said hey
you got games put it over here they want
to see what it do first
they not putting none of they first did
I heard somebody yell out Spiderman I
heard somebody say Last of Us board
games they ain't doing none of that
right there they threw our call why you
think call it a Wild Wings
why do you think because it was if the
second one flopped so they was like yo
you know what we got spin off on this
other spin-off machine
let's see if they can just make a Smash
Hit bro
the high hopes that y'all have for them
taking control and saying yo we're gonna
throw Spider-Man we're gonna go do this
we're gonna do that that state of play
showed you exactly where they at with
they ain't got nothing coming not the
Tyson not the Tyson thing
it's coming and all y'all got is hopes
and dreams that some third-party
developer take Monopoly and do something
special
y'all are gonna be sorely disappointed I
seen the same script and it was called
PlayStation VR1 I was there and I had 10
games y'all don't even got 10 games that
launched y'all said they got 30 though
they got bags they got 40 games boys
one of the biggest large lineups is
going yo straight up 50 games that you
can play other places
but that one game though that one game
that climbing simulator got you hot as
hell no no not gonna do it not gonna
fall for it I fell for that banana in
the tailpipe one thing I just stick
around and wait until they actually
decide to put some of the Top Flight
franchises in there and say you know
what we're going to support it for real
don't give me no Half Baked call it a
wild and with alloy peeking through the
window
you're doing great
if the dinosaurs we're out get out of
here man
I think you have it also um King's uh
feelings on me on psvr too so really
quick um the legendary [__] G makami uh
put out a statement in the left Tango
game work so um Studio Founders head uh
Department of common mumps and um we got
a statement I'm writing today this is
from um I think Bethesda yeah but that's
a a soft senior vice president Todd
Vaughn I'm writing they let you know the
studio head Shinji makami has decided to
leave Tango Games work in the coming
months he said but comedy sign has been
a creative leader and a supportive
mentor to Young developers at Tango for
12 years through his work on The Evil
Within franchise goes why Tokyo and of
course Hi-Fi Rush becoming is also known
as the creator of the Resident Evil
series during his 16 years at Capcom
founded Tango in March 2010 wow 2010 and
it was acquired by Bethesda armed Source
parrot company xenobax in October that
year and then there was an official
statement from uh Bethesda he says we
confirmed that he has decided to leave
and we wish bakami signed well in the
future we're excited about what lies
ahead for The Talented developers at
Tego and even uh Phil Dominus had put
out a nice tweet in reference to
makami-san you know thanking him for his
services and everything like that so uh
Lord had it never start with you
obviously we had recently had Tango
Games work in the in the building with
uh John Johannes director of high five
Rush shiji The Legend you love you love
Resident Evil you know this is your OG
this is one of your OG so how do you
feel about this
hey I think it's I think it was it was
happening you know he sold to Bethesda
I'm sure he made some kind of money off
of the actual buyout in general uh and
it's just like you know
Microsoft was probably like look
we're gonna give you this much to stay
for a certain amount of time after that
you can ride off into the sunset and you
know uh when when these companies are
bought like that one of the biggest
things they want is an easy transition
and I think that's probably one of the
reasons he stayed as long as he does
like
don't think Todd Howard's going to be
around for years either Todd Howard's
probably going to stay tall I would say
Elder Scrolls maybe even Midway through
the development Elder Scrolls and then
he's going to retire like these people
have been in the industry for years uh
sooner or later guess what Phil Spencer
gonna retire too uh and you know then
we'll see the Landscaping at that time
but you know I'd be surprised because I
saw somewhere
I don't know if it was an interview but
he was they were talking and he said he
felt more as a mentor at this point in
his life yes than an actual developer
and I think that's what he mainly wants
to do now is he probably just wants to
consult pop in play a game you know give
his opinions on something you know give
his opinions on uh gameplay direction or
maybe since he's in more of the horror
space maybe you know
consult on the next Resident Evil in
some way he just he just wants to be one
of those names at the end of the credits
I don't think he wants to be responsible
for an entire studio anymore uh and I
think that's it you know at the end of
the day uh he was it could be a
Microsoft thing maybe he doesn't want to
work for a big Corporation such as
Microsoft but at I think this was going
to happen regardless these people have
been in the industry for XX amount of
time they're eventually going to move on
do something different the good thing
what I liked he said is I have raised
the younger generation to easily take my
place and that's what I like uh because
that is the best statement I've ever
seen someone make yeah that's like it
does look like he hand-picked his
successor like no it's funny I'll add on
because um one of the conversations you
know I remember having with John house
we had John on for Hi-Fi rush and you
know he always said like he didn't want
to be pegged as the horror only studio
right and one of the things you know for
the his Ambitions for for Tango you know
was to expand and accept it have a young
John Johannes come in there and Pitch
this exciting deal so it seems like he
was is already setting up these like you
said I've added like these young
developers and he's actually said that
he actually feels it was passed on
articles I jump and I'm sorry because I
I added I'm done um is that he he
actually said he believes in having like
a team a young gun is like young
developers because he feels almost like
the game industry is you know it can't
be controlled by the older guys like
like the younger guys are in touch like
you know I'm saying that kind of deal so
I thought that was was quite interesting
so I just want to add on to your point
because he has said that exactly what
you alluded to addict in the past but uh
some of it makami-san the legend oh gee
Resident Evil this is the the what who
used to play lights off with the dog
come through the window this is the
ozivakami son the legend
I think Resident Evil was really one of
the first games like we you know we
heard about Miyamoto whatever but that
PlayStation one was was kind of like a
revelation and that's when yeah we were
a little bit older version did they say
who took over his position like yeah
he's not gone yet is he is he gone
already I mean I didn't know if they say
he was going to be taking over his
position in a few months he's gonna be
transitioned yeah they just said it was
well in the future and then fill
statement Thank You makami song for your
leadership and your great contribution
to the industry your guidance and input
over the last two years has been
valuable to me looking forward to our
continued friendship and then he says
I'm looking forward to what lies ahead
for Tango Gameworks Japan so yeah no
ideas when it's probably I don't know if
I'm just assuming you know that it's
going to become most of something that
he you know probably transitioning out
anyway we can take this off
yeah so like if also for me like res
evil like we were like you know whatever
early 20s or whatever and we
that's really the first time I started
paying attention to who's making these
games okay what the hell man I comes up
with this stuff like I really started
paying attention to everything around
gaming that just not not just the games
and
um yeah makami was one of those names I
was like oh [__] anything Shinji makave
touches that's it like whatever Resident
Evil 2 Resident Evil three four whatever
I'm in
so I'm just I'm glad sometimes you have
people that are at the top that don't
know when to let go when don't know when
to kind of you sort of feel like they're
very protective of their positions or
their statuses and in whatever industry
it may be and not afraid to teach and
afraid to let go and let the newer
Generations come in you know their
understanding of reading the room at
that time and understanding what the
market looks like and understanding what
Gamers want or whatever
um and I think just him acknowledging
that he's at the point of his life where
he'd rather just kind of step back give
guidance right
um and let the let the young kids play
as they say in baseball let the young
kids play you know and
I think it's important because and and I
think my hope is that he does stay in
the gaming space like when you look at
him when you look at somebody like
Miyamoto when you look at um Todd Howard
guys that have been around
the important thing about these guys is
that have been around from the beginning
right or in the early stages of gaming
is that they understand Gameplay at a
fundamental basic level
and that's super important because all
of that that's all building blocks for
what we have today none of it has really
changed that much they're just built
upon it in different ways utilized uh
the tech to sort of go into different
directions but at the end of the day the
building blocks of what make makes games
fun so the concepts are basic and those
Concepts were developed by These Guys
these you know the makamis and the The
Immortals so the fact that these guys
acknowledge that hey I've had my time I
want to impart what I know to a younger
generation let them run with it
um it's super important I think and you
know for him he gets the sort of
send-off that I think he's does he
deserved you talk about like igorashi
same thing leaving Capcom you know
although Konami I'm sorry dealing with
the whole like Castlevania stuff and
these guys yeah Kojima these guys that
have left their their companies and not
necessarily the best places just because
again whether they're all tours or
whatever whether the business side
conflicted too much with the art side
about it seeing these guys getting their
second and third Chances with other
Studios that they created having some
measure of success of being able to walk
away on their terms yes it's something
that I think is important and they
deserve right so again uh I'm glad to
see that he you know he went in like I
mentioned like you went in got that bag
from that sale right got the back from
the set of Bethesda you got another bag
from the Bethesda Center Microsoft
definitely Cash Out potential guys our
potential and he's he's able to walk
away or or just or impart knowledge on
his terms and it doesn't have to be like
I'm being run out of town and and that's
a great thing and not you know not every
developer has the opportunity to do that
so for him to be able to do it on his
terms I'm so happy for him and again
just happy for all the stuff he's
brought to gaming as we look at look at
Resident Evil man like res evil change
the game it really changed the game you
know King and I had this debate about it
but it's like you know he took all the
stuff that was in a little early you
know games that didn't play very well
alone the dark didn't play Super well
and he took those Concepts and turned it
into
a playable product that was think about
it think about
how hard it would be for a Sprite based
game or whatever 2DS right to really
scare you yes and he said take these
Concepts and put it into the 3D space
use polygons use pre-rendered
backgrounds in order to control exactly
in order to control the Fear Factor yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna scare you here and
this way and the angles he would put the
angle running from the distance to
things like he would certain parts
running out of corn or the older residue
would make you feel uncomfortable
because of the environment
and no matter what you did you couldn't
look around that corner you had that you
had to hold that be like all right
what's coming like and it's and it it's
it's again the things that he's brought
to gaming again building blocks of what
he's learned from people that came
before him I just love the fact that
he's able to to do things on his terms
and and and and it's humble in that no I
I'm gonna impart what I know to these
people coming up that's right sure for
sure Lord King makami-san The Legend
retires
you always like the if for you all you
younger guys right and you're going into
a career not a job yeah right so
like y'all have to change your mindset
and I'm gonna say that to you guys now I
preach it to my children
you look for a career not a job
a job you're going to be working on your
life a career you already started your
exit the day that you started your job
your career
because you you're planning right and
his plan pretty much was yo I'm gonna
leave on top I'm gonna put uh the
younger generation and places to succeed
and win and I can probably just be there
for them to call on me and give them
advice on certain things but
I I want to end here
and he's doing that you know a high five
rush just dropped to a critical success
by a young chapter that he has on his
channel Johannes does John does John get
the ball well yeah um I don't think so
okay
I don't think but I think he becomes a
studio head okay you know as far as you
know he's he he gets the next step up
his ranking in order of this is other
people that was in line gotcha well you
know John and and I believe in that
culture you don't want to plant that all
right
and and just you know start uh in
fighting for no reason this is not
necessary everybody know the hierarchy
uh
he's just made it to that point where
now he wants to
enjoy the fruits of his labor now
Xbox dudes you're gonna probably hear
Doom and Gloom oh okay he can't get
along with Microsoft Mike's okay man I
gotta go listen
same way with PlayStation
at Bungie million dollar retainer on a
lot of dudes that's there that's middle
and high management million dollar
retainer on these individuals to keep
them in place uh for that period of time
I think it's like a two-year period of
time three year period of time or
whatever and then after that you're able
to leave
I'm pretty sure Microsoft does the same
thing
all right so we need all management
because from what we hear but there's it
still operates separately yes from
Microsoft as business as usual and
they're not trying to come in and just
bug the situation yeah they want to see
how the internals work they want to get
the numbers how things work and see how
they can enhance and keep the same
status quo going forward right so
I guess he feels that the studio is so
sufficient we don't know how much impact
all or or uh help he gave in Hi-Fi rush
we don't know if it was just on a that
looks good type of thing and everything
was done by John and his team so again
he did say this is your baby yeah you
can drop it how you want to drop it when
you say that and he's side by side with
him you showing the Stars on your team
and it's in good hands he's letting you
know Tango is still Tangled but I'm
pretty sure it's mission statement
just like he said he didn't want to be
known as just the horror yeah that was
big when I heard that from him in Hi-Fi
Rush changed fast I agree right so he
walks out on top with him not being just
a horror guy and the studio is going to
be as diverse and multi-faceted going
forward and I think that's what
everybody needs so it's not Doom and
Gloom you know when somebody needs to
retire there's other reasons there's
family there's other things than chasing
the check in this world no for sure well
[__] um yeah it's alleged man this is
definitely you know one of the one of
the key pillars he probably doesn't get
a lot I don't feel he gets to deserve
the the the Kudos he deserves you know
kind of thing he's really you know what
we call it like uh survival horror you
know what I'm saying yeah I think that
term is one of the fathers of that you
know and it was him and then you know I
know shout out to the chat right now
they clown another take controls it was
Charming to me but at the time it was
graphically revolutionary and then let's
give them his more flowers for that wait
let's move it to where addicts ERA with
with the Resident Evil 4 where you
drastically change the formula right
yeah and you're still Resident Evil and
you still come back take the title we're
critically acclaimed right that that's
that's a big thing in itself to go
against your own formula right and then
succeed the way it is because a lot of
people even though I'm from the oh I'm
OG old school everybody for the old
school era a lot of people agree with
addict like Resident Evil 4 is his
greatest you know what I'm saying it's
the blueprint for every 3D action games
so straight up straight up so it's like
that GameCube is lit yeah GameCube did
like yo he did a lot dude obviously Evil
Within has a cult following it's really
love obviously John and them come on
board he pitches Hi-Fi rush to allow
that and then we've been hearing
Rumblings um since 2019 he's been
talking about retirement yeah so
pre-acquisition so he's been in the game
a long time so that's clear second thing
like Kate said he gets the ride out on
top you know which is awesome I'm very
curious if he's going to be in an
advisory role or at any capacity or I am
curious though the only flag that will
raise me I'm with you King whatever say
I think it's this man part of the game
is to cash out too and you've been doing
it a long time and you get to ride off
of the sunset
um I am curious though if it'd be like
yeah he's opening another
problem okay bro let's go then I'll be
like okay but for right then you're
gonna get another bag because you're
gonna go sell to another support that's
why they sell the 10 cents
put out another game that's a good part
look the end game is obviously you know
you have to do what's best for you at
the end of the day but I do think
Tango's in great hands I love what's
going on we're going to see what's going
on with John and the crew and yeah
that's really what you want to say but
salute to the legend man Shinji makami
absolute legend in the game but that's
all I got and uh yeah I'm gonna wrap
this up
yeah we don't have too many uh this is a
scene
let me see uh uh we got the rubber knob
remember for two years five dollars
which yeah TCL is worried about psvr too
they're expecting a huge increase in
warranty claims due to players knocking
their TVs sitting on the floor knocking
over their TV sitting on the floor wow I
thought
Jesus this is good we said the
PlayStations guys TV is a lot of flop
then we got splendiferous
15-month Lord bronze Lord I've got the
back door version the one that gonna let
a little breeze blow over the top of the
head to the back strap you say you gotta
find that sweet spot
wow you really you kind of filled in a
lot of blanks then bro yeah none of this
was it was directly I don't know what
Impressions he's giving off
vivid imagination hey that you gotta
tilt your head to find the sweets wow
yeah but he created a whole story around
there yeah
so he said you don't want to get back
North while it's tracking oh Mom
I didn't say that about back doors
moving on
I'll do control against dizzy like them
old Street Fighter 2 characters and I
gotta frantically match the buttons to
wake it back up I know this man did not
say that way
[Music]
I'm tired
I think I got jumped but I think we're
good I think that's it I think we all
good Lord addict where can the blind
people find you what you got going on
sir
follow me on Twitter Lord addict IOP
find me on YouTube at gaming addict I'll
be uh uploading some uh content next
week I can't say what content I'll be
uploading some content next week uh I'm
going to broaden a little bit of the
kind of content I make over there you
will find me on this Tuesday on the r r
with uh King uh we're gonna be talking
about a couple things unfortunately now
definitely gonna be talking about I
won't be talking about the cocaine Bear
movies
it it did make sense now thinking about
a king that that movie wasn't there why
would they care it's look like they
can't really have a movie go for one day
and and justify putting in that movie
theater so that's crazy yeah so uh
definitely I want to appreciate first of
all I want to appreciate all the people
that came through today almost 800
people in the chat okay
um you know that's what's up wait that's
what's up we are 13 away from 500 I'm
OCD I'm gonna need 13 of views yeah hit
that like oh hit it you hit the like hit
the like really how many 13 of you okay
9 8 12. I'm a bully you I'm bullying you
today
I need to read the poll that I forgot
yeah yeah okay and so yeah I appreciate
it oh we did not oh
um
patreon questions
nobody had no problem
normally I share them on Twitter
no questions but I do got to do
we will see you next week and uh be
looking out for my review on uh unknown
game sometime next week I said unknown
games
yeah he is definitely an NDA dude
definitely all right IOP if Microsoft is
allowed to acquire Activision Blizzard
which factor dude there we go for 500.
we'll be the most important we got it
that's what's up important to getting
the deal done so a the video G-Force now
as a competing streaming service having
Xbox games on their service B bringing
Call of Duty to over
150 more Nintendo consoles or see I
don't care I just want to see what's in
Brad Smith's envelope so those are the
choices go rock that out what do you
think is going to be the more if the
deal gets done out of those two digs
which one do y'all think is the most
critical factor to it getting gun so I
don't know where y'all at with it but
let's go up on Twitter anyway more soft
where can I find people find you what
you got going on sir
at work that's my life I'm gonna be at
work so I can't enjoy can't go play some
VR I can't play with my uh my new laptop
go to work no no no at work and it looks
like we have a box hiding uh
[Laughter]
it's hot ahead sucks on top of it
exactly when you put the headphones on
this exactly what it look like
howdy
yo you stupid Floyd King a lot of talk
today where can the five people find you
what you have going on Sir well you can
find me at Arnold the Lord's uh Tuesday
at 5 p.m Eastern Standard Time where
I'll be talking about cocaine bear
we also gonna um talk about we have a
ghost that's on Netflix right now it
just came out on Friday so uh addicts
movie theater don't need to carry that
isn't it and we'll be talking about The
Last of Us last week and this week's
episode so we have a lot of fun facts
and and jam-packed stuff there uh we
definitely will be talking about Creed
Three yeah we have a lot of stuff going
on I got to do uh my reactions to attack
on Titan attic has done his reactions to
chainsaw man nice uh and I think that's
about it right now I'm still watching
you I gotta watch a little bit more
episodes today not you specifically but
you the the show that's on Netflix which
is really fun and really creepy find me
on Twitter where I'm just uh I won't I
won't kick you out
I will definitely talk to you and I will
see why I'm not your favorite why are
you upset with me why you love me I need
you to love me no no again shout out to
the chat shout out to everybody that
pulled out man a lot of love good to see
you shout out to everybody that was at
the last day of media event again we got
big things cooking in the couple weeks
Pax is approaching we do appreciate your
support we're gonna get those goals and
we're going to do some things we got
other we got some fun things cooking so
look that's all I got again thank y'all
a lot of fun and we'll see y'all next
week in the round peace
[Music]
thank you